COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN A MERCHANT SEE AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS A NORMAL PRACTICE
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE. PROCESS
WHICH- WOMAN HERE- WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. MEMBERS
THAT WE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATORS MELENDEZ AND
SENATOR LET ALONE. AND ACTUALLY
HAVE A LOGGED IN YET OR NOT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SIR LIMóN IF-
WE CAN JUST RECOGNIZE YOU AND
INDICATE WHETHER YOU HAVE ANY
STAFF PEOPLE WITH YOU AT THE
MOMENT. NEARLY NINE PRESIDENT
PRESENTS IT I HAVE ONE STAFF
MEMBER BENJAMIN PETERSON HERE
WITH ME OKAY THANK YOU CEREMONY
AND- WHEN CENTER MELENDEZ- LOGS
IN AND- LOGS AND WE WILL HAVE
HER ALSO DO THE SAME THEN- AND
SERVES AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MEET YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATING ANY CUSICK
FEEDBACK. THEY ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE THE RAZOR HAND
FEATURE- WHICH WILL ALLOW AND
THAT- IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR
IT PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE. WHEN
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN. THAT YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. ACTUALLY.
ACTUALLY JUST CONSOLE THAT THE
SCREEN. YEAH. PRECIADO. TAKING
THANK YOU HE AND I. OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU AND I DO SEE CENTER
MELENDEZ IS ON SO SIR MELENDEZ
DO YOU HAVE WE WILL YOU PLEASE-
SAY HELLO AND INDICATE WHETHER
YOU HAVE A STAFF MEMBER WHO IS
WITH YOU AND THEN IF I THAT
STAFFER YEAH IF SO. SURE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I AM HERE
PRESENTS AND ACCOUNTED FOR IN
MY STAFF MEMBER IS AMANDA
FISHER WHO IS IN HER OWN OFFICE
RIGHT NEXT DOOR. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER MELENDEZ. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
LIMITED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING RUMORS TO THE EXTENT
ETCETERA DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ROOM IS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND WILL ALSO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS.
SEVEN SEVEN THREE SEVEN FOUR
SIX EIGHT. AGAIN. SEVEN SEVEN
THREE SEVEN FOUR SIX EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THE WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
AMITY WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND THEN
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
OTHERWISE WE'LL GET THIS ECHO.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. IT
IS ALSO MY RESPONSE WE HAVE
CHECKED THIS CHAIR TO MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
THAT IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE TO CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS CONDUCTED
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME TO
PARTICIPANTS WHO ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO TO DIE TODAY WE HAVE.
NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA-
WE'VE BEEN INSTRUCTED TO HEAR
THEM IN AUTHOR ORDER SO BY
ALPHABETICAL ORDER BY AUTHOR-
THIS ORDER MAY BE MODIFIED.
BECAUSE OF AVAILABILITY BILL
AUTHORS TO BE PRINT- WHO ARE
PRESENT IN THE NEED TO COMPLETE
THE HEARING AGENDA AND A TIMELY
MANNER. IN ADDITION- YEAH SO
OKAY BEFORE W HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS-
ACTUALLY DO WE HAVE QUORUM YET.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN NO BY THE COALITION OKAY
I DON'T THINK- WE'RE READY TO
TAKE A QUORUM YET SO WILL
CONTINUE AS A STEP DO WE HAVE.
THAT WE HAVE. FIVE MINUTES ON
THE PHONE. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THAT'S ENOUGH OKAY RIGHT WELL
ALL RIGHT SOUNDS LIKE WE DO ALL
RIGHT SO- LET'S GO AHEAD
ESTABLISH CORN THEN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS AND
HERE. MELENDEZ. HERE MELENDEZ
HERE EGGMAN. GONZALEZ GROVE.
GROVE HERE HER TADO. LEYVA
LEYVA HERE LIMON. SENATOR LIMON
PRESENT YOU ROTH- RIGHT HERE
RUBIO RUBIO HERE WIENER. YES WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. NOW FOR
BILL TESTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS ON REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MYSELF MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY. EACH
SIDE OF THE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I WILL PERMIT UP TO
TWO WITNESSES. FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH PER WITNESS TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS OR MAXIMUM FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY WAS LIMITED
COMMON CENTER NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURES. I
HOPE TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY HOWEVER
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
DEFINITIVE. THE SENATE DEFINITE
END TIME FOR THE HEARING I'M A
LITTLE BIT LIMIT TOTAL TIME FOR
ALL COMMENTS ON A BILL TO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEES ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY. EVERYONE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ON ANY BUILDING HER TODAY ON
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITES
OF YOUR UNABLE TO ACTUALLY
TESTIFY. ON THE TELEPHONIC LINE
OR IN PERSON YOU CAN ALSO
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY ON THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WITH
THAT. WE'LL GO AHEAD TO BEGIN
WITH OUR- FIRST ITEM SO- AGAIN.
ARE FOR. ITEMS ONE TWO AND
THREE ARE IN CONSENT SO OUR
FIRST ITEM TODAY'S I AM NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR GLAZERS I SEE THAT HE'S
HERE WELCOME. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU A- THANK YOU CHAIR
PANEL ON IT THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
VILLAGE DURING THE AUTHORED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. MUCH
APPRECIATION TO HER AND WE HAVE
CO AUTHORS FROM THIS COMMITTEE-
CO AUTHORS INCLUDE SENATOR
RUBIO AND WIENER AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATOR NIELSEN
FOR ALSO BEING A CO AUTHOR. SB
SEVEN FORTY NINE IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE. THAT WILL
PROVIDE INSIGHT TO POLICY
MAKERS AND STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
THE STATE. ABOUT HOW COUNTIES
ARE USING THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDS. AND HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
SERVING OUR CONSTITUENTS. WE
SPEND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR. IN AN EFFORT TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT WE HAVE
PRECIOUS LITTLE DATA. TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND WHICH OF THE
PROGRAMS WE ARE FINDING ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE. AND WHICH OF
THEM THEY'RE ACTUALLY HELPING
THE PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED
THIS ASSISTANCE. THIS IS NOT
JUST MY OPINION. IS THE VIEW OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
LAST SUMMER THE STATE AUDITOR
RELEASED A REPORT. DETAILING
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY FOR
HELL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS ARE BEING USED AND THE
BENEFITS FROM THOSE SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THAT
BASED ON THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR IT WOULD
CREATE A STATE FRAMEWORK FOR
COLLECTING INFORMATION ON
MENTAL HEALTH SPENDING AND
OUTCOMES. THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
UNDER THIS BILL THE COMMISSION
WILL BE REQUIRED TO COLLABORATE
WITH STATE AND LOCAL MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCIES TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE TRACKING PROGRAM.
FOR COUNTY SPENDING ON MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND THE
OUTCOMES FROM THAT SPENDING.
THE COMMISSION WOULD PROVIDE
ASSESSMENTS OF SPENDING OUTCOME
PATTERNS BY DEVELOPING
CATEGORIES OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES INCLUDING
EMERGENCY SERVICES AN INPATIENT
SERVICES. CURRENT REPORTING
RELIES ON A DISJOINTED
INCOMPLETE TOOLS ARE RESULTS OF
MULTIPLE FUNDING SOURCES. FROM
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AND
LEVELS OF TRANSPARENCY. L. AS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD SOLUTION TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND HOW COUNTIES
ARE SPENDING FUNDS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND HOW THESE
FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO IMPROVE
CONSTITUENTS MENTAL HEALTH.
WITH ME- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS TOBY EWING. OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU CENTER GLAZIER
LET'S NOW MOVE TO- TOBY EWING-
SO- MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
BRING TOBY EWING ON TO LINE
AND- ST LOUIS DR EWING YOU
HAVE. TWO MINUTES TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
TO BE DEALING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THE
BILL. SB SEVEN FORTY NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN TERMS OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL EFFORTS AND THE
COMMISSION. SPECIFIC EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. IF
THE INCLUDING THE FUNDS THAT
ARE USED THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND THE OUTCOMES THAT
ARE ACHIEVED. I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR LATER AND CO AUTHORS
PARTICULARLY HIS STAFF FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE IN THIS
BILL. THIS WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
COMMISSION TO ENHANCE WHAT
WE'RE ALREADY DOING AND TO
DEVELOP THIS. HAS DESCRIBED IN
THE BILL A COMPREHENSIVE
TRACKING SYSTEM ON SPENDING
PROGRAMS AND OUTCOMES- MANY OF
YOU ARE AWARE OF THE WORK THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS DONE ON
TRANSPARENCY OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SB SEVEN FORTY NINE IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR GOALS AND
THE WORK THAT WE HAVE UNDER
WAY- THE COMMITTEE IS AHEAD OF
THE COMMISSION IN TERMS OF THIS
WORK AND WE WILL BE FORMALLY
REVIEWING THE BILL- FOR SUPPORT
AT THE- AT A MEETING ON THE
TWENTY FIFTH- BUT IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR CHAIR. I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT THIS
REALLY DOES ALIGN WITH THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE UNDER WAY.
TOMORROW THE COMMISSION WILL BE
HOLDING A DATA FORUM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY SO OVERSUBSCRIBED
WE'VE HAD TO TURN PEOPLE AWAY.
THERE IS TREMENDOUS DEMAND FROM
THE PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE MONEY
THAT IS COMING IN THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE OUTCOMES THAT
ARE BEING ACHIEVED- SO WE ARE
VERY MUCH SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL I'M- I'M HAVING TO. LIMIT
MY ABILITY TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE. THE
COMMISSION HASN'T TAKEN A
FORMAL VOTE. BUT I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT IS. A VERY CAN. WITH
THE WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE-
THAT WE LOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR AND BEING ABLE
TO FORMALLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
BUT WITH THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT ANYBODY ON THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE REGARDING
OUR ABILITY TO DO THE WORK.
THAT THE BILL IS CALLING FOR.
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO- TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT TO
NAME ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION
ONLY FULL FIRST BEGAN WITH THE
GALLERY PUBLIC GALLERY. SAYING
NO IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FORTY TO TESTIFY AS MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES SWING
TESTIFYING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST SO
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR
NINE- PLEASE- PLEASE HAVE THEM
AVAILABLE. THEN LATER GERMAN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU A NUMBER AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT NUMBER
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR NINE
PLEASE PRESS. AND I WILL FIRST
MOVED TO NUMBER THIRTY THREE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. SB SEVEN FORTY NINE
THANK OU THANK YOU EXLINE.
ONCE YOU HAVE YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH NOW LET'S MOVE-ON TO OPPOSITION- SO TESTIFYING%
IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE A
BILLION. DOLLAR DEAL SORRY BUT
MISPRONOUNCED THAT- THAT FROM
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SO IF YOU
CAN PLEASE BRING- THE PERSON ON
TO THE LINE TO TESTIFY TWO
MINUTES. HELLO AM I ON THE LINE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YOU ARE
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU DR PAN
AM CENTER WILL INDUSTRY CAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS OUR
CONCERNS WITH SB SEVEN FOUR
NINE I'M AT LEAST I GOT A CALL
I'M REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. WHILE WE APPLAUD
THE INTENT OF SB SEVEN FORTY
NINE C. B. C. B. H. THE EIGHT
IS CONCERNED WITH THE LANGUAGE
AND SB SEVEN FORTY NINE
REQUIRING COUNTIES TO REPORT.
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION OR THE COMMISSION IN
A MANNER DETERMINED BY THE
COMMISSION A MULTITUDE OF
INFORMATION WHICH IS ALREADY
ACTUALLY BEING REPORTED TO
OTHER STATE ENTITIES. COUNTY
HAVE TO REPORT MEDICARE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES BILLING DATA
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FIFTY EIGHT YES
TO SECURE FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION WE ALSO ANNUALLY
REPORT. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT EXPENDITURES D. A. YES AN
EXTENSIVE. I MEAN FOR THREE
THREE YEAR PLANS AN ANNUAL
UPDATES. WHICH INCLUDE PROGRAM
LEVEL OUTCOMES DATA AND IN TURN
THE DEMOCRATS SAY INFORMATION
IS ACTUALLY ALREADY SHARED WITH
THE COMMISSION. A REQUIREMENT
TO SUBMIT THE EXACT MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF DATA TO ANOTHER STATE
ENTITY IN A MANNER REQUESTED BY
THAT STATE ENTITY IS OF
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN AND
ACTUALLY THIS IS THE ONE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT WE
ARE OPPOSED TO. BECAUSE OF THAT
YOU PUT IT IN. IT BECAUSE IF
YOU COULD GET OF THESE IF
YOU'RE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND WOULD ADD SIGNIFICANT
UNNECESSARY COSTS TO THE COUNTY
THAN THE STATE I'M- IT AS
ACCURATELY OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND TO REITERATE. THE
BAFTA DONE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOLAN THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY SIMILAR
BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE-
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX AND
LOOKED AT ACCOMPLISHING VERY
SIMILAR GOAL. BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH A BILL EXTENDING
THE SCOPE OF THE COMMISSION
AUTHORITY OUTSIDE THEIR AREA OF
EXPERTISE WHICH IS STATUTORILY
LIMITED TO THE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. THIS
EXPANSION WOULD BE IN AREAS
THAT ARE ALREADY OVERSEEN BY
OTHER STATE ENTITIES PRIMARILY
THE ACS THE COMMISSION. SPOKE
OF THE STORY IS CLEARLY THE
OUTLAW. WHEN WELFARE IN. CODE
SEX. FIVE EIGHT FOUR FIVE WHICH-
LIMITS THEIR ARE ALREADY THE
MATH HEALTH OF ACT. SB SEVEN.
HE'S BEEN LEADING UP. SURE
UNTIL THIS IS THIS IS A CONCERN
THAT WE'RE AT OVER OUT AND AT
THE OR WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ABSOLUTE THE GOAL THE END AND
THAT THIS BILL A LONGER CAN
BUILD WE'RE ON ON SPRING
TOGETHER. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TEST THANK YOU LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO SHELTER OUT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
WILL BEGIN WITH THE- SAY NO ONE
THE GALA LET'S ROOM MOVED
TWENTY FOUR. SAYING NO ONE ROOM
TO FORTY- LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE SO
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FORTY NINE- WE WILL BEGIN
SO PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FOUR
NINE. STANLEY LAWMAKER IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB. SEVEN
FOUR NINE. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NONE IN OPPOSITION OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR REMOTE MEMBERS
PLEASE USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FUNCTION. OR OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK TOBY EWING AND- WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND AS A
AS A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION I THINK THAT WHEN
THIS COMMISSION WAS CREATED. A
TO Z. MISTER EWING TO LEAD THIS
COMMISSION WAS SOME. PRETTY
PHENOMENAL IDEA AND SO- HE'S
DONE AN OUTSTANDING JOB AND I
THINK THAT IT'S ADDED VALUE TO
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING MENTAL
HEALTH. THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CENTER
EGGMAN. ALSO JUST TO AND- THINK
THE AUTHOR AND AM SO HAPPY TO
BE WORKING WITH HIM ON THIS. TO
REALLY GET OUR ARMS AROUND ALL
THE STREAMS OF MONEY THAT'S
GOING INTO TREATING ARE FOR
FOLKS WITHOUT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. AND IF WE CAN IF WE CAN
SEE WHERE IT'S ALL COMING FROM
AND WHAT WORKS BEST. THEN I
THINK WE HAVE A MUCH HIGHER.
CHANCE THAT UNCERTAINTY. OF
REALLY BEING ABLE TO TREAT
EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS TO BE
TREATED SO THANK YOU AND I'LL
MOVE THIS BILL. OKAY SO THE
BILLS- WILL BE MOVED IT FROM
THE TIME TO CENTER EGGMAN US
ARE RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I JUST WANNA LIVE MY
COMMENTS CLOSELY WITH STUFF THE
GREAT SENATOR FROM STOCKTON.
WHO JUST MADE COMMENTS AND I
THINK THIS IS SUCH A SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BATTLE. I WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT COUNTIES AND STATES
THAT WERE ALL. USING MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING AN INEFFICIENT
ENTRANCE CAN WEIGH IN WITH THAT
I WILL ALSO URGE AN EYEFUL
THANK YOU AND ALSO PROUD TO BE
A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THAT
CENTER ROCK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU KNOW- TYING INTO WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE JUST SAID THE I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION. AND
WE CERTAINLY WANT EFFICIENCY
AND EFFECTIVENESS IN
GOVERNMENT. BUT IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR WHEN YOU LOOK UP AND DOWN
THE STATE AND CERTAINLY WITHIN
OUR- RESPECTIVE OF THE SENATE
DISTRICTS THAT. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE.
STILL BE APPEARS TO BE A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. YET
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS DEMAND.
FROM ALL DIRECTIONS. MANY AREAS
OF OUR STATE ARE. CERTAINLY
UNDERSERVED. AND THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT WITH RESPECT TO
MENTAL HEALTH. FUNDING AND
SERVICES. AND TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION WE SIMPLY NEED TO
GET A HANDLE. ON WHERE THIS
MONEY'S GOING HOW IT'S BEING
SPENT AND WHETHER THERE IS.
SUFFICIENT SEE AN EFFECTIVENESS
IN THIS ASPECT. OF GOVERNMENT
SERVICES SO I CERTAINLY COMMEND
THE- THE VARIOUS AUTHORS
ATTACHED TO THIS BILL. FOR THIS
EFFORT AND I'M SURE AS IT MOVES.
FOR IN THIS. TO THE OTHER AND
HOPEFULLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK FOR SIGNATURE THAT. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE ANY ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE FIXED THEIR
FIXED BUT THAT THIS BILL GETS
PASSED AND SIGNED. AND WE HAVE
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
RESPECT TO THE EXPENDITURE OF
FUNDS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE STATE. SO WHAT
I REGION I VOTERS WELL THANK
YOU MR. THANK YOU CENTER OFF
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN YOUR
HANDS UP ON THE REMOTE SITE.
YES SORRY GONZALEZ. YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING IT FORWARD I
DO HAVE JUST ONE QUESTION- TO
CLARIFY IF I MAY THROUGH. THE
CHAIR COURSE- THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER JUST ONE QUESTION IS AYE
I KNOW THIS NEARS THE AUDIT IN
TERMS OF COUNTY. HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS BUT I HAVE US CITY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND SOME
WONDERING IF THAT. THERE'S ANY
THOUGHT INCLUDING THAT OR HOW
THAT WOULD BE- WORKED. THROUGH
THE CHAIR- YES I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION BUT
WOULD BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU DIRECTLY THE FOCUS WAS
ON THE COUNTY REPORTING. BUT
LET ME CHECK ON THAT AND NOT BE
HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU WHAT I
KNOW. THAT BE WONDERFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING NINE THE-
CIRCULATION I TO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I WOULD JUST- MAKE AN
OBSERVATION IS- A PAST CHAIR OF
THE SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE ON BUT
JUST OF CAN BE A HEALTHY HUMAN
SERVICES THAT OVERSAW- BOTH
MEDIC AL IANS- THE- THE MSA
MONEY ANY IMAGES THEY MIGHT IS
THAT- WELL WE CERTAINLY ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE- THE PROP SIXTY
THREE MONEY AND WE HAVE THE
MEDICAL MONEY- WE ALSO HAVE
FRAGMENTATION IN TERMS OF NOT
ONLY OF COURSE FOR THE MONEY
GOES BUT ALSO. IN TERMS OF
OUTCOMES AND- I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND SO THE OPPOSITION
SAYING THAT THE ORIGINAL
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR THE
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION WAS JUST
OVER THE PAST SIXTY THREE MONEY
BUT WE NEED A BODY THAT
OVERSEES ALL OF IT RIGHT AND-
DOWN THEN IT'S WAS PASSED WHILE
AGO- CERTAINLY YES THERE IS
REPORTING TO DTS AND WE NEED TO
DO THAT FOR YOU KNOW FOR
FEDERAL MATCHING MONEY AND FACT
ACTUALLY US IN LATER IF YOU
COULD JUST ADDRESSING YOU CLOSE
THE DUPLICATION ISSUESWHICH I
THINK ARE CERTAINLY ONES WE
WANT TO BE SURE WE ADDRESS- THE
IN TERMS OF DUPLICATION WE
DON'T HAVE A COUNTIES HAVE TO.
DUPLICATE REPORT AND SPEND MORE
MONEY ON THAT SO HOW DO YOU
LINE THOSE THAT WE MINIMIZE
THAT OVERHEAD COSTS THERE DOES
NEED TO BE AN AGENCY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE OVERLOOKING ALL OF
HER MENTAL HEALTH ACROSS THE
STATE I THINK AUTHORED IN A
FIGHT THAT APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD SO
WE CAN DO EXECUTE ON THAT AS
WELL- THAT WITH THAT- I'D
CERTAINLY I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR PAN YES INDEED MEMBERS AT
SEVEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AND IS REVENUE COMING
IN FROM MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
OUR STATE SEVEN POINT FIVE
BILLION BUT IT COMES IN FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES WITH SOME OF
IN SOME CASES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN
OTHER CASES. NO ACCOUNTABILITY
AND NO REPORTER REQUIREMENTS WE
DON'T WANT OVERLAPPING
REPORTING. SYSTEMS- AND- IT
WOULD BE MY HOPE- ANY KERN
REGULAR. OR LAW ON THE TODAY
REQUIRE THAT DUPLICATE WOULD BE
ELIMINATED. ONCE WE CREATE
THIS- DIRECTION THAT'S FOR
THAT'S PRESENTED IN THIS BILL.
THE AUDITOR DID LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT THIS ISSUE. AND
THEY DESIGNATED THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. AS
THE ONE THEY THINK CAN DO THE
MOST EFFECTIVE JOB. IN
COLLECTING AND REPORTING ON THE
STATUS. THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE OPPONENTS-
WHOEVER IS THE TODAY. AND
COLLEAGUES IN THE OTHER HOUSE
WHO ARE GOING ON A LITTLE BIT
OF A DIFFERENT PATH. TO
RECONCILE THESE ISSUES AT IT
THIS BILL IS ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND WITH THAT LET ME
THANK YOUNG THE- SENATORS FROM-
RIVERSIDE AND BALDWIN PARK. AND
STOCKTON AND BAKERSFIELD AND
SACRAMENTO. GRACIOUS COMMENTS
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE IT. AND
I VOTE. RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
CENTER GLACIER- SO THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER AG AMEND
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
PAN HI MELINDA'S SENATOR
MELENDEZ ON S. B. SEVEN FORTY
NINE HI MELENDEZ AYE EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN AIKEN SALAS HI AND SALAS
I GROW. HER TADO LEYVA LIMON.
SENATOR LIMON SB FIVE FOUR
SEVEN FOUR NINE RIGHT SB SEVEN
FOUR NINE HI. LIMON I ROTH ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER.
SEVEN THE BILL CURRENTLY IS
SEVEN ZERO OR HOLD THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MUCH SENATE GLAZER. OKAY
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE
X. FIVE BUT LET ME JUST I DON'T
THINK I'VE REALLY READ OUT THE
CONSENT ITEMS SO THEY JUST DO
THAT BEFORE YOU GO ON TO NEXT
BILL SO JUST A REMINDER I
CONSENT ITEMS ARE. ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FIVE FORTY ONE BY BATES
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FIVE SIXTY
FOUR BY CORTEZ A AND ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB TWO EIGHTY ONE
BY DODD SO WE'RE GOING TO NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER. FIVE SB
TWO NINETY THREE FOR A TOTAL
AMOUNT WILL BE PRESENTING AT
REMOTELY- WELCOME AND- PLEASE
BEGIN SETTLEMENT. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND TAKING
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO THIS
ISSUE THE EARLY AND PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT E. P. S. D. T.
PROGRAM IS A STATE ADMINISTERED
MEDICAID BENEFIT ENTITLING LOW
INCOME INFANTS CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE ENROLLED IN MEDICAID
AS WELL AS FOSTER USE THREE
COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. ONE OF THE
LARGEST COMPONENTS OF THE
BENEFIT IS INDIVIDUALIZED
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES WHICH
INCLUDE CRISIS BASED SERVICES
COUNSELING AND THERAPY
INTERVENTION AND MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT COUNTIES CURRENTLY
RECEIVE LIMITED GUIDANCE FROM
THE STAY ON HOW TO COMPLY WITH
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO THE PROGRAM AS A
RESULT PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS
VARY WITH EACH OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES USER UTILIZING
DIFFERENT SETS OF PAPERWORK TO
ADMINISTER THE SAME TYPE OF
SERVICE. THIS CREATES.
CONFUSION FOR PROVIDERS AND
RESULT IN CHILDREN EXPERIENCING
CRITICAL GAPS IN CARE AND A
LACK OF COORDINATED CARE WHILE
ALSO INCREASING. COSTS TO THE
ENTIRE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY'S AND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS ON
HOW THIS INTERACTS WITH THE
CURRENT CALTRAIN
IMPLEMENTATION. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE'REHAPPY
TO AMEND THE BILL AS I STATED
EARLIER- TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND
COORDINATE THOSE ACTIVITIES
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO MEANS THE
STREAMLINED AND SATURDAYS
INTAKE ASSESSMENT. AND
TREATMENT PLANTS WITH THE USE
OF CONTRACTED PROVIDERS IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. WHAT ME
TODAY ON THE PHONE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL ARE- NEAR MORE AND
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND NANCY FACTOR. DIRECTOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FROM LIKELY
GOT THAT ACCENT. THANK YOU
CEREMONY AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING WITH MY STAFF NOW LET'S
GO ON TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SO FOR- TESTIMONY SUPPORT-
LET'S BRING ON THE LINE. IT'S
MIRA MORTON FROM CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL CALIFORNIA DOES
HOSPITAL SOCIAIS ASIAN FOLLOWED
BY NANCY FACTOR FROM LIKELY TO
CUT THE LA RAZA SO. MODERATELY
PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE LINE
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
TESTIFIED. THE MAYOR MARTIN IS
ON THE LINE RIGHT YOU MAY
BEGIN. WELCOME THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS NEAR
MORTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND A PROUD CO
SPONSOR AT THE TWO NINETY
THREE. TWENTY FIRST FORMED A
WORK GROUP OF OUR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ISSUE OF
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DOCUMENTATION RAPIDLY FLOATED
TO THE TOP OF THE MAJOR PAIN
POINTS.THEY NOTED IT CONSUMES
4250% OF A BRIGHTER TIME
REQUIRED OUR THE TRAIN TO
COMPLETE CORRECTLY AND IS A
LEADING DRIVER BURNOUT AND
ATTRITION FOR THERAPY FOR THE
MEDICARE POPULATION. IN THE
FLIGHT AT THE TWO NINETY THREE
IS REALLY A WORKFORCE BILL IN
THE STATE IS IN DESPERATE NEED
OF A MORE AND MORE CAPACITY AT
CHILDREN'S. SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE. CAN
REPRESENTATIVE. AND THE
COMMITTEE AND I. FOR POINT OUT
THAT THE ADMIN. PLAN TO ADDRESS
SOME ASPECTS OF THE PAPERWORK
BURDEN THROUGH TELLING. AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THIS ATTENTION
THIS ISSUE IS RECEIVING AND FOR
THE COMMITMENT THE COUNTY TO
DATE YES I'VE ALREADY MADE TO
IMPROVE THE SITUATION. HOWEVER
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THESE
CHEMICALS ARE NOT AND THIS IS
WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP. IF WE ARE
TO TRULY FREE OF THESE
PROVIDERS TRYING TO DO WHAT
THEY DO BEST AND MAXIMIZE
ACCESS TO THESE INVALUABLE
SERVICES THE EFFORT MUST BE PUT
STANDARDIZATION AND G.
DOCUMENTATION AND GUIDANCE OF
THE COUNTY. KNOW WHAT CAN'T IT
CAN'T BE ADDED BEYOND THE
STANDARDIZED FORM. SPECIAL
SIGNAL PROVIDERS FREQUENTLY FOR
CHILDREN IN MULTIPLE COUNTY
SOMETIMES MORE THAN TEN. AND
EACH COUNTY REQUIRED DIFFERENT
FORMS AND INTERPRET THE STATE
REQUIREMENT DIFFERENTLY. THE
FORCE OF PROVIDERS TO CREATE
COMPLEX TRAINING ANNUAL TO TAKE
TIME AWAY FROM PATIENTS TO
LEARN WITHIN THEM. FOR THIS
REASON WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT CAN ACHIEVE ITS
STATED GOAL THAN TELLING
WITHOUT STANDARDIZATION.
IMPORTANTLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
A HISTORY OF STANDARDIZING FORM
AND BENEFIT WHEN NEEDED TO
ELIMINATE CONFUSION AND
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO CARE.
FOR EXAMPLE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL-HEALTH SECRETIVE INTERNET
CONTRACT SERVICE AUTHORIZATION
PROCEDURE. AND A SET OF
DOCUMENTATION STANDARDS
INFORMED TO ENSURE FOSTER
CHILDREN PLACED OUTSIDE THEIR
HOME COUNTY. WHICH BUILDS WITH
THE SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND AGAIN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE EGISLATURE REQUIRE
REGULATORS TO STANDARDIZE THE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FORM USED
BY MANAGED CARE PLAN FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG APPROVAL.
AMPLE EVIDENCE THAT A SIMILAR
EFFORT IS NEEDED IN THE FACE
AND FOR THIS REASON WE URGE YOU
TO PASS AT THE TWO NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
NANCY FASTER WITH. THE LIKELY
BECAUSE THE LA RAZA. THANK YOU
RICHARD PAN AM. I'M HONORED TO
BE THERE TO AND- THE- IN THE-
URGENCY IN INCREASE. ACCESS TO
MENTAL CARE FOR INSTANCE
CHILDREN AND ADULTS. AND WILL
IN MANY. FROM THE DIRECT
BEHAVIOR HAVE THAT MUCH. GOD
THE LEAD AFTER IN THE SIMPSONS
BECAUSE AREA. WE OFFER. TO EPS
TO PROGRAMS. TO DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. IN THE DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS DIFFERSIGNIFICANTLY IN EACH COUNTY.
RESULTING IN THE NEED TO RUN TO
DISTINCT PARALLEL PROGRAM.
WHICH IS INEFFICIENT DUPLICATE
SCARCE RESOURCES. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY REDUCES AVAILABLE
STAFFING THAT WE NEED FOR
DIRECT SERVICES. IN OUR PROGRAM
ALONE WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
SUPERVISORY VACANCIES. AND OUR
CLIENTS WOULD HAVE MUCH BETTER
ACCESS TO CARE IF WE COULD
STREAMLINE ACROSS. COUNTIES
RATHER THAN DUPLICATE. ACTOR
THAT THEM. IS HIGHER CLIMB
DEMAND AND GREATER. THE
SEVERITY WERE GROW GRAY EACH
DAY WE ARE REALLY STRUGGLING TO
MEET THE NEEDS. YET ACT THERE
OPEN SPEND 3240% OF THEIR TIME
ON DOCUMENTATION. DISBURSING
MISSTATED LOWER STAFF MORALE
INCREASES TURNOVER AND DEPLETES
ARE SCARCE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
WORKFORCE. LET ME GO ALONE HAS
TEN THERAPIST VACANCIES AND
THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO US. EACH
THERAPIST WE LOSE IN SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH IS A SIGNIFICANT
LOSS CAN TAKE YEARS TO REPLACE.
REDUCTION IN WORKFORCE
OBVIOUSLY RESULTING RESTRICTED
ACCESS TO CARE AND FOR THE
THERAPIST THAT STATE TIME USING
DOCUMENTATION THAT. DOESN'T
HAVE QUALITY ACCOUNTABILITY
REDUCES ACCESS FURTHER INTO
SOME VACANCIES TURNOVER
DUPLICATION DISPROPORTIONATE
TIME SPENT ON DOCUMENTATION.
ALL WE DO IS ACCESS TO THE TIME
WHEN THE DEMAND FOR CARE IS
HIGHER THAN EVER. MY
PREDECESSOR LESLIE PRESTON
ADVOCATED FOR DOCUMENTATION
REDUCTION IN STREAMLINING AND
STANDARDIZATION FOR A DECADE.
SHE DIED SADLY THREE YEARS AGO
WAITING FOR THIS MOMENT AS
LESLIE WOULD SAY. LET'S PROVIDE
CARE FOR THE PATIENT NOT THE
CHART. THE PANDEMIC REQUIRES WE
ACT NOW LET'S NOT WAIT ANY
LONGER TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO OTHER ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY THREE- NAME OR EXIT A
POSITION ONLY WE'RE GOING TO
GET OF THE PUBLIC GALLERY.
SCENE ON THE. PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S REMOVE THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THANK IT ROOM FORTY
LET'S MOVE TO THE TOP. LINE SO-
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PER IN THE
WILL TO TEST IN SUPPORT. OF SB.
TWO NINETY THREE. AND LATER
JOHN ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB TWO NINE THREE. WELL FIRST
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AM
FLIGHT CHANNEL LANDECK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS WENDY **** WENT HALFWAY
THROUGH THE MARCH PERSPECTIVE
TO NOT HELP PROVIDER IN L. A.
COUNTY WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB. TWO NINE THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THE
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR PAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SUGGEST ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
AND CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
EIGHT PROUD CO SPONSOR SB TWO
NINE THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXLINE. NEXT NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF MY NAME IS
MARIE COLLINS FROM COMPETITION
FOR CUSTOMERS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES AND WE'RE
CALLING TO VOICE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SD. TWO NINE THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXLINE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CHAIR NUMBERS MRS COLLINS
FOR US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXLINE. NEXT
TO MOVE TO LINE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HOKEY
AMERICA AND I'M CALLING FROM
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB TWO NINETY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXLINE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE FIFTY YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU EXLINE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES THAT
PROBLEM BONDURANT SUPPORT- SB
TWO NINE THREE. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX OR THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HE LATE MONDAY HALF OF
THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO LINE
FOURTEEN LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE A MEMBER
WITH THE TORONTO ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE IS THE PART OF A
SPEECH ABOUT THE BIG. THANK YOU
EXLINE. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE MR CARE ACT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MODERATOR THAT NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO NINETY THREE WE DO HAVE-
PAULO WILL HìNH. FROM THE
COUNTY HERE HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- YOU I
WILL GIVE YOU A LITTLE I'LL
GIVE YOU MORE IN TWO MINUTES
JUST BECAUSE THEY GOT TO GET TO
PEOPLE BUT IF YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
REMARKS SHORT. IF MAXIMO FOUR
MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DESERVE HELLO WELCOME CAN YOU
ALL HEAR ME. I GUESS PLEASE
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WE
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND AS
YOU KNOW CAN YOU OPERATE
SPECIALTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANS THAT COVER SERVICES FOR
MEDICAL BENEFITS. WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS INCLUDING YOUTH
SERVICES PROVIDED CHILDREN
THROUGH THE EPF EASY PROGRAM.
AND PICK CLARIFIER POSITION
TODAY WE ARE SHARING CONCERNS
WITH F. B. T. NINETY THREE BUT
WE CERTAINLY CAN GET CONCERNS
RATHER THAN FORMALLY OPPOSED
THE BILL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WE
SHARE IMPORTANT OVER ARCHING
GOALS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
PROPONENT. ALONG WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDER
COMMUNITY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS HAVE CONSISTENTLY
ADVOCATED TO SIMPLIFY AND
STREAMLINE. DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS. AT A CURRENTLY IN
TO FIRST GIVEN HEALTH U. P. S.
B. THIRD. WERE UNABLE TO
SUPPORT THE IN ITS FORM WE ARE
ULTIMATELY NOT SURE THE
PROPOSAL AND AT THE G. NINETY
THREE WILL BE NEEDED ONE FOR
THE STATE HAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
DOCUMENTATION REFORMS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INTEGRATING MEDIC
HELLENISTIC SAYS FOR CALLING.
THE CALENDAR TO KEEP WAIVER
PACKAGE INCLUDES SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSALS THAT WILL COMPLETELY
CHANGE THE WAY SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE DOCUMENTED
AND CLEAN. PROPOSED REFORMS
INCLUDE CHANGES TO MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PAYMENT REFORMS ANYTHING
VERY SPECIFIC PROPOSALS TO
ALIGN DOCUMENTATION STANDARDS
WITH SCHOOLS THE EXCESS
ELSEWHERE AND MEDIKAL AND AT
THE FEDERAL. LEVEL FOR MEDICAID
AND MEDICARE. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE NEW. STANDARD FOR ME NOT.
DOCUMENTATION AS ENVISIONED IN
CALENDAR. WILL LARGELY
ALLEVIATE THE NEED FOR THE
STANDARDIZED FORM STRATEGY
PROPOSED UNDER SB TWO NINETY
THREE. WE ALSO THINK ITWILL BE
IMPORTANT THAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS AND PROVIDERS
WORKS TO FULLY IMPLEMENT CAL IN
REFORM BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
POTENTIAL AND WIDE RANGING.
BEFORE ASSESSING WHETHER KALYAN
HAS HELPED TO SOLVE OR SYSTEMIC
DOCUMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
TAKING FURTHER ACTION ON
CHANGES LIKE THE STANDARDIZED
FORM PROPOSED IN THE BILL.
JERRY JERRY WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
THAT CALIBER FORM WILL
MEANINGFULLY AND FINALLY REDUCE
THE EXCESSIVE DOCUMENTATION
BURDEN THAT HAVE CHALLENGED OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
AND PROVIDERS ALIKE THROUGHOUT
THE HISTORY OF THIS PROGRAM. WE
EXPECT CALLING TO GET A COMPLEX
MUCH OF WHAT THE CELTICS TO
ACCOMPLISH AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
PROPONENTS AN AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER WITHDRAWING THE
LEGISLATION. AND THE FOCUS ON
LAYERING YOU REQUIREMENTS FOR
STANDARDIZED FORM. AND INSTEAD
FOCUS ON EFFORTS TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO DEVELOP SIMPLIFIED
AND STREAMLINED DOCUMENTATION
PRACTICES UNDER CALAMP THAT
ALIGN WITH THE WAY SERVICES ARE
DOCUMENTED ELSEWHERE IN MY
pMORE BROADLY. SO I WILL CLOSE
BY THINKING THE AUTHORED THE
SPONSOR FOR A DIALOGUE FIFTY
EIGHT AND EXPERTS TO BUILD
CONSENSUS ON THIS AND- SYSTEMIC
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I CAN
ABOUT ARE CONCERNED. THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FOR
TESTING AFTER. TO TWO NOW THREE
NAME OR- AND POSITION ONLY WILL
BE ABLE TO GALLERY. SCENE KNOWN
AT THE GALLERY LET'S REMOVE
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SAY
NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELEPHONIC LINES
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO SB TWO NINETY
THREE. AND LATER ON IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. TWO NINETY THREE. AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NOBODY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S NOW MOVE TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS STEP PLEASE
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE
OF EUROPE. TO SPAIN REMOTELY. I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE AT THE MOMENT.
OKAY SAYING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- IT'S FINE TO SAY-
CEREMONY I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
I DO ACKNOWLEDGE FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT- IN THE TELLING
PROCESS THROUGH BE A
SIMPLIFICATION PROCESS BUT I
ALSO UNDERSTAND- FROM THE
SPORES OF YOUR BILL IN YOUR
EFFORTS TO SAY THAT
STREAMLINING IS RATE BUT IT'S
STILL GOING TO BE DIFFICULT IF
WE DON'T HAVE SOME
STANDARDIZATION SO THAT YOU
HAVE ENTITIES TO HAVE MOLD. THE
SERVE MULTIPLE COUNTIES HAVING
STILL TRAIN PEOPLE IN A MORE
STREAMLINED SYSTEM IN MULTIPLE
WAYS THAT THAT THAT THAT WE
WILL MISS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO REDUCE THE OVERHEAD AND
REDUCED ADMINISTRATIVE WORK-
THAT- ARE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
WILL HAVE TO DO AND TAKE THEM
AWAY FROM PATIENT CARE SO
CERTAINLY I'M A BRACE FOR THE
BILL APPRECIATE YOU WORKING MY
COMMITTEE STAFF TAKE IMMENSE-
CENTER LIMóN WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIR AND I WILL ACTUALLY USE
AT YOUR COMMENTS AS MY CLOSING
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I. THANK YOU CENTER ALONE IS
THERE A MOTION TO. FOR THIS
BILL OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER EGGMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
I MELINDA'S. SENATOR MELENDEZ
ON SB TWO NINETY THREE AYE
LANDIS AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
AND SALAS HI PLUS I GROW. HER
TADO LEYVA ALL LEYVA I LIMON.
THEN EARLY MULLIN ON S. C. TWO
NINE THREE HI LIMON I ACROSS.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. NINE OKAY
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS NINE
VOTES NINE ICE- WILL LEAVE THE
BILL BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO CENTER
LIMóN- WE'RE NOW GONNA TAKE UP
YOUR NEXT BILL SO THIS ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT. SAN RAMON. PLEASE PM ME.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT REQUIRES
ALL HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
TO SHARE HOW MUCH CONSUMERS
HAVE PAID TOWARDS OUR
DEDUCTIBLE AND MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET LIMITS DURING ANY MONEY
THAT'S BENEFITS WHERE THERE
USED MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE COVERAGE WITH DEDUCTIBLES
SOMETIMES OVER A THOUSAND OR
EVEN AS MUCH AS SEVEN THOUSAND
OR EIGHT THOUSAND IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET. NO STATE LAW
REQUIRES PLANS OR INSURERS TO
INFORM CONSUMERS ABOUT WHERE
THE CONSUMER IS IN MEETING THAT
DEDUCTIBLE THE BURDEN OF
TRACKING IN NAVIGATING THAT
AMOUNT TOWARDS ANY DEDUCTIBLE
FALLS STRICTLY UPON THE
CONSUMER HEALTH PLANS HAVE
INFORMATION ON RELEASE IT CURLS
SINCE THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REIMBURSING ANY PAYMENTS BEYOND
THE MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT SHIFTS THE
BURDEN OF KEEPING TRACK OF THE
WEEK YOU'RE A GIRL TOWARDS THE
DEDUCTIBLES AND MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKETS. FROM THE CONSUMERS TO
THE HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS.
TODAY WITH ME ARE- DIANA
DOUGLAS FROM HEALTH ACCESS AND
pLAW. ON WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU CEREMONY
LET'S NOW MOVE TO OUR TO THE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT- SO
MODERATOR. WE NEED DIANA
DOUGLAS- FROM HEALTH ACCESS AND
CHEN FLORIST IN THE WESTERN
CENTER LONG POVERTY SO DIANA
DOUGLAS WHEN YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE AGAIN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DIANA DOUGLAS
FOR HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIA
THE STATE WIDE HEALTH CARE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION
HERE AND SPONSORSHIP OF SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT. ALMOST TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DEDUCTIBLES MANY OF WHICH ARE
IN THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND
ON TOP OF THAT CALIFORNIANS
WITH PRIVATE COVERAGE. ALTHOUGH
THE MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET
LIMIT. WORKING FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET OR
FACING DIFFICULT EXPENSIVE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS TRACKING OR
CRUEL TOWARD THE AMOUNT. THE
CRUCIAL PART OF FINANCIAL
PLANNING IN THE ACCEPTING CARE.
EXACTLY THREE SIXTY EIGHT WILL
PLACE THE BURDEN ON HEALTH
PLANS TO TRACK VEHICLE AMOUNT
AND COMMUNICATE THEM TO THEIR
OWN BELIEFS. A NEW FEDERAL ROLE
WILL REQUIRE PLANS TO SHARE
THIS INFORMATION WITH CONSUMERS
BUT STILL REQUIRES THE CONSUMER
TO REQUEST THE INFORMATION.
THAT WE PROPOSE SHIFTING THE
BURDEN FROM THE INDIVIDUAL TO
THE HEALTH PLANS THAT CONSUMERS
FACING SIGNIFICANT HEALTH NEEDS
ARE LEFT IN THE DARK. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH LANGUAGE
BARRIERS OR THOSE WHO LACK
FINANCIAL LITERACY THE BURDEN
SHOULDN'T FALL ON THEM TO HAVE
TO HUNT DOWN THE INFORMATION.
SB THREE SIXTY ABLE REQUIRE THE
PLANS TO REGULARLY UPDATING BUT
LIKE IF. SOMEONE RELEASED
ALREADY RECEIVE CEO PETER
EVIDENCE OF BENEFIT STATEMENTS
WHICH INCLUDE THIS INFORMATION.
AND WE ALSO ALREADY KNOW THAT
THIS IS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PLANS
PROVIDED UPDATES FOR THE WHILE.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIRS FROM
CORPORATE AMENDMENT THAT
CLARIFIED THE TIMING OF NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE HEALTH
PLANS AND TO CLARIFY THAT
RELIEF WILL HAVE THE OPTION TO
OPT OUT OF MAIL NOTICES.
REQUEST ONLY ELECTRONIC UPDATE.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT MALE NOTICES
THAT THE DEFAULT OPTION ARE
CRUCIAL TO MITIGATE EQUITY
ISSUES FOR PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
HIGH SPEED. INTERNET OR
SMARTPHONE APP. THANK YOU AND
THESE THREE WE ARE TO SPONSOR
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT RESPECT
REQUEST YOUR I GOT. THANK YOU
DAN DOUGLAS. NOW LET'S BRING
CHEN FOR FROM THE WESTERN WEST
CENTER ON FOR A LONG. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS JENNIFER WHAT'S
CENTER ON POP. CURRENTLY
CONSUMER ARE TRUCK REQUIRED TO
KEEP TRACK OF ALL THEIR
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES AND
SELF CALCULATE WHEN THEY REACH
THEIR DEDUCTIBLE OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM. FEW PEOPLE CAN EXPLAIN
ALL OF THE COST SHARING
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEIR PLANS
WHEN CONSUMERS RECEIVE A BILL
FROM A PROVIDER MANY OF THEM
THEY OWE THE AMOUNT THEIR BUILD
FORGE RATHER THAN ADEQUATE THEY
HAVE ALREADY ACCRUED TOWARD
THEIR DEDUCTIBLE OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM. THIS IS ASKING THOSE
WITH THE LEAST KNOWLEDGE OF
INDUSTRY PRACTICES INTERMENT
TERMINOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES AND
JUSTICE SOMEBODY WITH ALMOST
TWO DECADES OF HEALTH ADVOCACY
EXPERIENCE I STILL STRUGGLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE BILLS THAT I GET
FROM PROVIDERS AND UNDERSTAND.
WHAT AND HOW I ACTUALLY- MORE
OR- CONSUMERS ARE MOST LIKELY
TO HIT THEIR- OUT OF POCKET.
WHEN THEY HAVE HAD A MAJOR
HEALTH EVENTS. SUCH AS AN
ACCIDENT REQUIRING EMERGENCY
CARE OR A CANCER DIAGNOSIS. IN
THOSE STRESSFUL TIME KEEPING UP
WITH ANY FINANCIAL MATTERS THE
CHALLENGE. INITIAL BURDEN OF
UNDERSTANDING HEALTH PLAN
POLICY TERMS AND CONDITIONS IS
MORE THAN AND CONSUMERS CAN
BEAR. IN ADDITION MANY LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR CREDIT AS
HAVING BAD CREDIT AND LIMITED
RESOURCES CAN MEAN OUT MEAN
LOSING OUT ON HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES PAYING HIGHER
INTEREST. ONLY HAVING ACCESS
THAT. SUBPRIME PRODUCTS LIKE
PAYDAY LOANS. ALL TOO OFTEN THE
CONSUMER WILL PAY A BILL FROM A
PROVIDER EVEN IF THEY ARE NOT
CERTAIN THAT THEY- THAT PHIL
BECAUSE THEY FEAR WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO THEIR CREDIT. FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS EVEN IF THE
OVER PAYMENT IS RETURNED BY THE
PROVIDER WHICH IN ITSELF CAN BE
A REAL CHALLENGE BECAUSE
PROVIDER OFFICES ARE NOT SET UP
TO PAY PEOPLE. MONEY THAT IS
TIED UP IN HEALTH CARE BILLS
NEEDS OTHER BILLS ARE NOT PAID.
OR THEY FOREGO NEEDED SERVICES.
INCLUDING FUTURE MEDICAL CARE.
FOR CONSUMERS WHO HAVE MET
THEIR DEDUCTIBLE OR OUT OF
POCKET MAXIMUMS HERE IS LIKELY
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY CHEAPER FOR
THEM FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
YEAR. IN THE CASE OF THOSE WHO
HIT THEIR OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM. THE REST OF THE CARE
THEY RECEIVED THAT YEAR THREE.
HOWEVER WITHOUT IT BEING
COMMUNICATED THE CONSUMER MAY
AVOID CARE ALL. TOGETHER AT
PRECISELY THE TIME WHEN THEY
MOST NEED IT AND WHEN IT
FINALLY AFFORDABLE. EVER
INCREASING DEDUCTIBLES AND OUT
OF POCKET MAXIMUMS TRAIN
CONSUMERS NOT TO GET THE CARE
THEY NEED. THEY SHOULD BE
INFORMED WHEN IT IS MOST
ADVANTAGEOUS FOR THEM TO GET
CARE. BECAUSE THE HEALTH PLAN
AND SURE WOULD RECEIVE
INFORMATION FROM ALL OF THE
PROVIDERS THAT CONSPIRACIES
THEY'RE IN THE BEST. POSITION
TO TRACK HOW MUCH OF A
DEDUCTIBLE AND OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUMS THAT CONSUMER. HAS
ACCRUED. FOR THIS. WE RESET.
ASK FOR YOUR I. AND THANK WITH
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK- TEN
FOR NALGONDA ON ADDITIONAL IN
SUPPORT AND MORTGAGE AS ONLY
BEGIN WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY.
PLEASE PLEASE- INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BRANDON MARCHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU LET'S NOW
REMOVE THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAY NO TESTIMONY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
TELEPHONIC SERVICE MODERATOR WE
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN. FAVOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT.
GERMAN INSURANCE SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB. THREE SIXTY EIGHT. AND
WE'LL FIRST MOVED TO NUMBER
FORTY FIVE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO KAREN MEMBERS
SERAPH BOX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. THEN
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO- NEXT
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER FIFTY TWO
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS DAVID
INVOLVED ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
POSITION GROUPS HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN TRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANKS LINE. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER FORTY NUMBER FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS THIS IS
FRED NO WE'RE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL
RESEARCH AND MANUFACTURERS OF
AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MR I
THANK YOU NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT WE HAVE THE GALLERY
NECKLACES FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS- SINCE
THEIR PROPONENTS GOT FORM. USE
THE MAXIMUM I HAVE OF COURSE
YOU ALSO HAVE AVAILABLE TO FOUR
MINUTE MAXIMUM TIME THAT STATE
PARK. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICK LOUISE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
WE'VE RESPECTFULLY TAKEN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL. WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE INTENSE WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THE CONCEPT OF THE
BILL HOWEVER MEMBERS HAVE FLAG
SOME OPERATIONAL CONCERNS THAT
MUST BE SOLVED BEFORE THIS BILL
COULD BE WORKABLE- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE LEVEL OF
DIALOGUE VIA THE SENATOR'S
OFFICE AND WITH THE SPONSORS.
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS- SOME OF WHICH ARE
HELPFUL- BE AMENDMENTS OVER
GOING INTO THE BILL REQUIRING
PAPER MAIL IS THE DEFAULT
COMMUNICATION MATH MECHANISM.
REQUIRE FURTHER ANALYSIS ON OUR
PART- THEY DO SEEM TO BE MORE
OF AN H. ISSUE FOR HMO MODEL
PLANS ARE PPO MODEL PLANS- IF
WE ON OUR IDE CAN DEVELOP SOME
ALTERNATIVES WE LIKE THE AUTHOR
IN THE SPONSORED TO- CONSIDER
MORE STREAMLINED. AND EFFICIENT
APPROACH BUT WE ALSO NEED A
DELAYED EFFECTIVE DATE OF IN
THIS BILL OUR PLANS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING TOWARDS
COMPLIANCE DATES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE FEDERAL RULES ON THIS
VERY TOPIC- THIS BILL GOES
FURTHER THAN THOSE FEDERAL
RULES AND WE THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT- IF
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. SO WE
LOOK FOR FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SPONSORS- AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NECKLACE- NOW IT'S MOVE ON TO
THE DITION OPPOSITE TESLA OPPA.
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY BEGAN WITH THE
PUBLIC GALLERY SEE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SINGLE WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. LET'S MOVE NOW TO.
WITNESSES ON LANES TESTIFIED
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WE INTENSIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT. ANALYSTS GERMAN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION- SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE WILL FIRST GO TO
NUMBER FORTY SIX LINE FORTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON THE AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS THE CAP ALSO
PUT MOST AMENDED AT THE MOMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NEXT TO A GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
NINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAN MEMBERS
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION AND- OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU MODERATOR
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NEED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE HERE TO SEE
REMOTELY- CENTER LEYVA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
HAVE NO IDEA I HAVE ANTHEM BLUE
CROSS PPO AND I HAD NO IDEA
THAT ALL PLANS DON'T ALREADY DO
THIS AND I FIND IT VERY HELPFUL
THAT I CAN GO ONLINE. AND SEE
WHAT'S BEEN PUT TOWARDS MY
ANNUAL DEDUCTIBLE FOR MY ANNUAL
POCKETMAXIMUM AGE I JUST THINK
IT'S A GREAT PLANNING TOOL AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SHE'S
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD SO
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A
BENEFIT TO EVERYONE WITH ALL
HEALTH PLANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER LEYVA ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEING NONE- IT'S A SERUM. AND
WHATNOT OKAY SO ALONE- I WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
ACTUALLY- WELL THE OPPOSITION
DID INDICATE THAT THEY WANTED A
LONGER TIMELINE THAT ACTUALLY
MANY PLANS. READY CAN PROVIDE
THIS. AND THE FACT IS THAT I'D
BE SURPRISED IF ANY PLAN TO
ACTUALLY SUCCESSFULLY
FINANCIALLY OPERATE WITH
ACTUALLY HAVING THIS
INFORMATION RATE THEIR FINGER
TIPS. SO SINCE THEY DO TRACK
INNOCENTLY- I NEED TO KNOW THAT
INFORMATION TO TAKE ISSUES
ABOUT HOW TO SHARE IT WITH
OTHER MEMBERS. SO AGAIN MY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU WORKED WITH
OUR COMMITTEE TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE DO TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE SO MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER OF AMOUNT. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND- I WILL I WILL
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS IN CLOSING
AND ALSO ADD THAT. I YOU KNOW I
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO FIND SOMETHING
WORKABLE- ENDED YOU WANT TO
GIVE CREDIT TO THE FACT THAT
SOME PLANS ALREADY DO THIS- AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL. CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDER A PLAN TO HAVE THE ACCESS
TO THIS INFORMATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. EIGHT THANK YOU CEREMONY
THERE A MOTION. TO MOVE THIS
OKAY IT'S A MOVE BY CENTER
LEYVA. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. A
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I AM A LINDA'S.
MELENDEZ ON SB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT NOW. MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I AND SALAS HI GONZALEZ
I GREW FURTADO. LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE LIMóN. GENERALLY MULLIN SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT HI. LIMON AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. ONE SO THE
VOTE IS CURRENTLY EIGHT ONE
WITH ONLY THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SEVERAL AMOUNT RIGHT- NEXT TIME
IS GONNA BE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
S. B. TWO FIFTY BY MYSELF SO-
CENTER EGGMAN I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO TAKE GO AHEAD TAKE THE CHAIR
YOU CAN DO IT FROM I THINK FOR
THAT TRY TO OPEN THE DESKTOP
PROTOCOLS WHEN WE COME TO A
MEMBER QUESTIONS I REALIZE
GIVEN WHERE YOU'RE SITTING AND
I'M ALSO MONITORING I WILL TRY
TO SIGNAL WHO HAS HER. HANDS UP
AND SO FORTH BUT TAKE IT AWAY
CENTER OKAY THINK YOU'RE MUCH
WELCOME CENTER PAN- PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT YOUR BILL S.
B. TWO FIFTY THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN SB TWO FIFTY ADDRESSES
INEFFICIENCIES IMPOSED BY
HEALTH PLANS TO INCREASES
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THE LACE
CARE REDUCES TIME SPENT ON
PATIENT CARE THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
STUDY PUBLISHED IN ANNALS OF
INTERNAL MEDICINE FOUND THAT
OUTPATIENT POSITION SPENT ONLY
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF THEIR
TIME ON DIRECT CLINICAL FACE TO
FACE TIME WITH THE PATIENTS AND
ALMOST HALF OF THEIR TIME ON
WHAT'S CALLED DESK. WORK AND
EHR DOCUMENTATION. IN TWENTY
EIGHT SAID PUBLISHED IN MESS
FOUND THE FAMILY PHYSICIAN
SPENT MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR
TIME EACH DAY AND WHAT THEY
CALL. DESKTOP MEDICINE. OTHER
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THE 2250% OF
A PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS TIME
INVOLVED ACTIVITIES. WHICH
MUSEUM COMPENSATED. RELATED TO
THE PATIENTS THAT WEREN'T ACT
EVEN SCHEDULED FOR THEM THAT
DAY INCLUDING. TELEPHONE CALLS
AND EMAILS FOR MINISTRY OF WORK.
AS WE STRUGGLE WITH THE PRIMARY
CARE SHOULD WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
TOO MUCH CLINICIAN TIME. OVER
HALF FOR MOORE'S CONSUME BY
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK AND SPENT
INSTEAD OF SPENDING TIME WITH
THEIR PATIENTS. SB TWO FIFTY IS
ABOUT LEADING OUR PET DOCTOR
SPEND. MORE TIME WITH PATIENTS
AND LESS TIME WAITING TO HEAR
FROM HEALTH PLANS. THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO NEW PRACTICES BY
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS THEY'LL
EASE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND THEIR
PATIENTS FREEING UP TIME
EXPENSE WITH ULTIMATELY
IMPROVES CARE FOR PATIENTS. NOW
WHEN YOU SEE A POSITION HEALTH
PLANS MAY REQUIRE THEIR
AUTHORIZATION FIRST. FOR YOUR
POSITION TO BE PAID FOR THE
CARE THEY PROVIDE OR FOR
PRESCRIPTION THAT MAY BE
WRITTEN FOR IT TO BE COVERED A
PROCESS KNOWN AS PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. THIS PROCESS IS
USED TO REDUCE UTILIZATION OF
CARE IDEALLY TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY CARE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT ALSO INCREASES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN TO
RISKY RECEIVE A TICKER SERVICES
ARE PRESCRIPTIONS. IN FACT ON
AVERAGE EACH POSITION COMPLETE
ABOUT TWENTY NINE POINT ONE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS
PER WEEK. THE TAKE AN AVERAGE
OF FOURTEEN POINT SIX HOURS TO
PROCESS. PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS
DELAY CARE ESPECIALLY FOR AFTER
HOURS AND WEEKEND CARE THIS
POSITIONS WAIT FOR APPROVALS
AND HEALTH PLANS AS THEY ARE
WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. SO
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THIS. SB TWO
FIFTY WOULD CREATE A GOLD CARD
PROCESS FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE A RECORD OF
OBTAINING APPROVALS A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST AND
HEALTH PLANS INSURERS. SO THEY
HAVE TO SHOW THAT THEY ARE GOOD
ACTORS THE DEAR ONES WHO MAKE
APPROPRIATE CHOICES. THE BILL
REQUIRES THE PART MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND PART OF SURE IS
TO DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY BASED
ON CALCULATIONS IN THE BILL
THAT WOULD QUALIFY PROVIDER FOR
TWO YEARS OF DEEMED APPROVED
STATUS. TO THE PROVIDER WOULD
NOT HAVE TO SUBMIT. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS FOR HIS
OR HER PATIENTS THEIR BY TAKING
UP VALUABLE PATIENT TIME. TIME
WHEN A PHYSICIAN DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE A PATTERN
OVER THE UTILIZING SERVICES.
USING ORDERING UNNECESSARY
SERVICES THEY SHOULD BE FREED
FROM THE BURNS A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. THERE'S ALSO AN
AUDIT PROCESS FROM IN THE BILL
TO ALLOW HEALTH PLANS INSURERS
TO CHECK. TO SEE IF THE
PROVIDER STATUS SHOULD REMAIN.
SB TWO FIFTY ALSO SET UP A
PROCESS WHEREBY CERTAIN
FACILITY BASED PROVIDERS CAN
GET PAID THE FULL CONTRACTED
RATE BY HEALTH PLANS INSURERS.
FOR SERVICES PROVIDED IN THE
CONTRACTED FACILITY WITHOUT
HAVING TO BILL AND COLLECT COST
SHARING FROM PATIENTS. WHO ARE
RECOGNIZED INSURERS ALREADY
HAVE STAFF AND SYSTEMS FOR
COLLECTING PAYMENTS INCLUDING
PREMIUMS. I THINK THE BURDEN OF
COLLECTING COST SHARING
PAYMENTS ON TO PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES. REQUIRES THEM TO
HAVE STAFF DUPLICATE THE SAME
FUNCTION OF PAYMENT COLLECTION
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF SCALE
AND LIKELY LESS EFFICIENCY AND
GREATER EXPENSE TO DO THE SAME
FUNCTIONS. BOTH OF THESE
PRACTICES TOGETHER WILL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARD EASING BURDENS
ON PROVIDERS AND PTIENTS AVOID
DELAYS IN CARE AND DIRECTING
RESOURCES TO PRACTICES. THAT
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES. I AM
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
AMENDMENTS THOUGH CLEAR FIND
IMPROVE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILLS DESCRIBED AN ANALYSIS. A
MOCK UP IS ALSO BEEN PROVIDED
THE MAN IS CLARIFIED
DEFINITIONS IN THE BILL MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE COST SHARING
COLLECTIONS REQUIRED IN THE
BILL IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
CONTRACTING PROVIDERS FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED AT IN NETWORK
FACILITIES. I HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BRIAN MARTY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IS IN THE GALLERY. AND THEN
I'LL ALSO INTRODUCE DR MASER
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING FROM THE
PHONE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE FIRST WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL-
BECAUSE OF LIMITED TIME I'M
GOING TO YIELD THE REMAINDER OF
MY TIME TO DR MASER ON THE
TELEPHONE. BUT HAPPY HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
GALLERY. OKAY THEN WILL PLEASE
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR THE
WITNESS THERE. YES WE CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR CHAD MAYES
ARE SAN DIEGO OTOLARYNGOLOGY IS
REPRESENTING THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. POSITION PRACTICES
AND NOT BEEN IMMUNE TO THE
ECONOMIC DEVASTATION OF THE
NINETEEN ON THE ONLY 30%
DECREASE IN INPATIENT BEDS THAT
15% INCREASE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH PPPS SAFETY PROTOCOLS
COUPLED WITH EVER INCREASING
NONCLINICAL COSTLY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
INCLUDING SELLING APPLES AND
BURDENSOME PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
IMPACTING TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
AND CONFUSING PATIENTS TRYING
TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM. AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR OWN
RESPONSIBILITIES WE NEED TO
HELP MAKE PRACTICES FREE TO
FOCUS ON IMPROVING HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT THE BODIES
FINALLY ACCESS TO CARE I JUST
STARTED WRITING THE CONFUSION
PATIENTS SPACE AND
UNDERSTANDING THEIR OWN HEALTH-CARE COVERAGE S. B. TWO FIFTY
DOES THIS BY TACKLING TWO BIG
OBSTACLES TO THAT GOAL PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND BILLING FOR
PATIENT COST SHARING. IN A
SURVEY SHOWS THAT PROVIDERS
AVERAGE THIRTY THREE FIRE
AUTHORIZATIONS ARE WE CONSUMING
NEARLY TWO WORKING DAYS EVERY
WEEK 90% REPORTED THE GROWING
FIRE AUTHORIZATION INTERFERE
WITH CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
HAVE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON HEALTH
OUTCOMES BHAIRAB PROPERTIES
CONTRIBUTE TO ADVERSE EVENT
THAT THE WASTE TREATMENT
RESULTED PATIENTS ABANDONING
CARE ALTOGETHER. EVEN
PHYSICIANS MAY SURRENDER TO THE
ON REASONABLE AUTHORIZATION AND
I OKAY I'M SO FRUSTRATED TRYING
TO ADVOCATE FOR THEIR PATIENTS
SO CUMBERSOME INTERRUPTED
BUSINESS PROCESS. SB TWO FIFTY
WORK WITHIN CONSTRAINTS OF
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT RELATING
PHYSICIANS WITH A PROVEN RECORD
OF APPROPRIATE UTILIZATION FROM
HAVING TO FILE FIREFOX. WITH A
FEW YEARS. KNOW WHETHER A
CONTRACT POSITION REQUIRE
GENERALLY ARE WE ARE A FEW AND
RARELY DID NOT. SUCH PROVIDERS
BE GROW REALLY BY FROM COMP
FIVE THE MAN. SUBJECT TO. RE
THIS APPROACH ALLOWS TO TIME
ACCESS TO NEEDED SERVICE
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
ALLOWING MORE TO PAY CARE.
DELAYS IN CARE AND REDUCING
CALL THIS IS A PRACTICES EVEN
PAY SHOULD BY RE OF THE-
REVIEWS STATE OF OFFICE. I'M
MEDICAL DIRECTORS WHILE
MAINTAINING CONTROL OF OUR
BUYERS SEEKING AUTHORIZATIONS
THAT MAY NOT MEET CLINICAL
CRITERIA. THE SECOND ISSUE IS
COLLECTION OF PATIENT COST
SHARING FACILITY SETTINGS BY
REQUIRING PLAYERS TO COLLECT IN
RALEIGH CARSHARING AMOUNTS
DIRECTLY. BASED ON AGREEMENTS
PLANS MAKE WITH THE ENROLLEE.
POSITIONS YOU SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES COLLECTING COPAYS AND
DEDUCTIBLES TO PATIENT CARE
ALREADY PROVIDED. THROWING HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PRODUCT AMPLIFY THE
PROBLEM. PATIENTS GET CONFUSED
AS WHAT WHEN THEY RECEIVE BILLS
FOR DEDUCTIBLES AND COST
SHARING FROM ONE OR SEVERAL
DOCTORS RESULTING IN THE LATE
OR NO PAYMENTS. PHONE CALLED
DOCTOR'S OFFICE IS CORRECT
NATIONWIDE THEIR PLAN IS ASKING
THE BANK. ACOSTA PRACTICE IS
ATTEMPTING TO RECOVER AMOUNTS
DO THEM WITH YOUR APPROVAL.
THIS BURDENS PRACTICES WHICH
OUGHT TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
PROVISION OF CARE BUT INSTEAD
END UP SERVING AS EXPLAINERS
AND COLLECTORS OF YEAH.
UNMOUNTED THERE'S A CONTRACT
BETWEEN THE PAIR AND THE
INSURER AND PURCHASE YOUR
INSURANCE MARKETS ARE NOT THE
POSITION. SB TWO FIFTY SIMPLIFY
THINGS FOR PATIENTS BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF BILLS THE PATIENT
RECEIVED FOR POSITION SERVICES
TO A SINGLE PAYER FROM THEIR
PLAN. I THINK THE BILL FROM
THEIR PLAN AND ONE STOP
SHOPPING TO CALL FOR ANY
CLARIFICATION OF CONTRACTUAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO PAY FOR
SUCH SERVICES. IT FREES UP
PRACTICE RESOURCES TO DEDICATE
MORE TIME TO DELIVERY PATIENT
CARE. AND HELPS PRACTICES
REMAIN VIABLE IT REDUCES
PHYSICIAN ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS SIMPLIFIES BILLING ON
QUESTIONS ABOUT BILLING FOR
PATIENTS. AND CAN RESULT IN
OVERALL COST REDUCTION CARE.
I'M HERE TO AN ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AS A FRIEND AND
MARK. I RESPECTFUL ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON IMPORT EASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF ANYTHING BEFORE WE GO. FOR
WHEN IS DR PAN CLEAR. ISSUE A
THE A MAN. YES ACTUALLY- SORRY
WAS IN MY NOTES ABOUT IT BUT I
THINK WE AREN'T ACTUALLY TAKING
AMENDMENTS RIGHT HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE CELL. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THIS BILL WOULD BE
PRESENTED WITHOUT AMENDMENTS
TODAY JUST FOR THE RECORD OKAY-
IS THERE ANY OTHER WITNESS IN
THE GALLERY NO ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
I SEE NONE- I WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
FIFTY AND THEN WILL BEGIN. IN
LATE GERMAN- IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO FIFTY. AND
FIRSTLY GO TO LINE TWENTY LINE
TWENTY YOUR AT. THANK YOU CAN
START ON ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER THIRTY THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FRANK BENCH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WOULD LIKE THIRTY SIX
HAS DROPPED WHO MOVED TO NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN IF GO
HEAD. NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PUTIN NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER FIFTY NINE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS CHRISTINE SCHULTZ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I WILL GO TO NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY SIX LINES OPEN.
HE MOVED TO NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN- NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITHOUT
OBJECTION BATON CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR MAT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BUT ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
OPPOSITION AND THE SUPPORT SIDE
I'D TALK FOR FOUR MINUTES SO
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE WE- ALLOW
THE OPPOSITION TO HAVE. THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME SO I WILL RUN MY
TIMER AS YOU GO I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SENATOR EGGMAN. THIS IS NICKEL
RESULTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
AND WE'RE REGRETTABLY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO FIFTY-
THE BILL CONTAINS MULTIPLE
MAJOR PROVISIONS- THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE VERY PROBLEMATIC IN
ALL THE ADDRESSING THE
PROVISION RELATED CITY PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION PIECE. MEMBERS IN
OUR VIEW THE PRIOR OFF
PROVISION OF THIS BILL
INSTRUCTS THE ABILITY OF MY
MEMBERS TO APPLY COMMON SENSE
CHECKS AND BALANCES THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. HEALTH PLANS
CURRENTLY WORK TO ENSURE THAT A
RELEASE ARE GETTING THE RIGHT
CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME AT THE
RIGHT LOCATION IN PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION IS KEY TO THAT
WORK. IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS. MANY HEALTH PLANS ARE
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING THEIR
OWN ENHANCE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
PROGRAMS TO HELP EASE THE
BURDEN ON PROVIDERS AND
ENROLLEES. AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC PLANS OF STREAMLINED
PROCESS EVEN FURTHER IN SOME
CASES EVEN SUSPENDING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. UNFORTUNATELY
SIZE FITS ALL MANDATE THAT IS
OUTLINED IN SB TWO FIFTY WILL
DISRUPT THOSE EFFORTS. THE
SCOPE OF SB TWO FIFTY IS
PARTICULARLY ALARMING. THE BILL
GIVES SPECIFIED PROVIDERS ARE
FREE PASS FOR MANY CHECKS AND
BALANCES FOR A PERIOD OF TWO
YEARS. WITHOUT ANY ABILITY FOR
THE HEALTH PLAN TO AUDIT-
DURING THOSE TWO YEARS. AT THE
END OF THE TWO YEAR PERIOD
HEALTH PLANS WOULD ONLY BE
ALLOWED TO REVIEW A MAXIMUM OF
TWENTY CASES ACROSS ALL PRODUCT
TYPES. AND WE THIS IS HARDLY A
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ENROLLEES ARE
RECEIVING THE RIGHT CARE- UNDER
TWO FIFTY PRIOR AUTH IS WAIVED
FOR ALL SERVICES. AND DRUGS
RENDERED BY THE PROVIDER. THIS
WAIVER WULD APPLY EVEN
SERVICES THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH HIGHER RISK F FRAUD WASTE
AND ABUSE OR NEGATIVE SIDE
EFFECTS. SB TWO FIFTY TAKES NO
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FRAUDULENT WASTEFUL CARE DOES
NOT INCREASE DURING THAT TWO
YEAR PERIOD. ALSO CONTRARY TO
THE ASSERTIONS OF THE
SUPPORTERS- SB TWO FIFTY
ACTUALLY INCREASES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND HEALTH CARE
BY CREATING A NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT IS BURDENSOME
ON BOTH HEALTH PLANS AND OUR
PROVIDER PARTNERS. WHICH IS ONE
REASON WHY THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY IS NOT UNANIMOUSLY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THIS
MEASURE COMES AT A TIME WHEN
THE ENTIRE HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY
IS COLLECTIVELY GRAPPLING WITH
THE ECHO OF NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
BY AND WE FEEL THAT EXCESSIVE
LEGISLATION AT THIS TIME- IS
UNHELPFUL FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE POST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YEAH WE WERE THE FIRST IN THE
GALLERY FOR ON THE PHONE. OKAY
ON THE PHONE THEN ANNA AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES LEFT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR STEPHANIE
WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE TO STAY
IN OPPOSITION I WOULD ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES REMARKS REGARDING
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL THAT
DEALS WITH PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
AND PROTECTION TO WHAT SHIFT
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COLLECTING THE CO PAYS
DEDUCTIBLES AND COST SHARING
PROVIDERS TO PLAN. WEEK WE HAD
SERIOUS CONCERNS AS WE NOTED IN
OUR LETTER THAT YOU GOT THE
SENATE FOUNDATIONAL SHIFT IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OPERATES
MOST CONSUMERS ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS WITH A MONTHLY
PREMIUM PAYMENTS ARE DUE TO THE
HEALTH PLANNER INSURER AND COST
SHARING COPAYS DEDUCTIBLES AND
COINSURANCE OR GO DIRECTLY TO
THE PROVIDERS HERE. THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO FINALLY TALK ABOUT
PRACTICE BY NOW REQUIRING PLANS
TO REIMBURSE HOSPITAL BASED
PHYSICIANS AT A 100% AND
COLLECT THE PATIENT COST
SHARING ON THE BACKEND DIRECTLY
FROM THE PATIENT. THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY PROBLEMATIC AS OUR
PROVIDER RATE CONTRACTS INCLUDE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEET THE CURRENT
BILLING AND COLLECTIONS AND
POSSIBLY IN ADDITION ARE NO
LONGER GOING TO BE TASKED WITH
THAT RESPONSIBILITY WE NEED TO
RE OPEN ALL OF OUR CONTRACT
THAT JUST READ BASED ON THE
CHANGE. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE
CHANGE WOULD BE FACTORED INTO
THE CURRENT SYSTEM HOW THE NON
COLLECTIBLE FACT THAT THE
MEDICAL LOSS RATIO CALCULATIONS
THE NON COLLECTIBLE FACTOR IN
THE RATE DEVELOPMENT. NOW TAT
THE PROHIBITS PLANTS FROM
TURNING AND- YOU'RE INSURED FOR
NON PAYMENT OF COST SHARING AND
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITS HOW THEY
CAN COLLECT THE PAYMENT WE SEE
A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
COLLECTIONS. WITH THE REDUCTION
IN COLLECTIONS GIVEN PLANS
INSURERS WILL BE CHASING THE
MONEY MONTH AFTER THE FACT
FIRST OF MANY HOSPITAL DAYS
AFTER COLLECTED PRIOR TO THE
POINT OF SERVICE. ANOTHER ISSUE
OF CONCERN IS THAT THE BILL
ONLY IMPACTS HE COMMERCIAL
MARKET THAT MEANS THAT
PROVIDERS WOULD STILL NEED TO
HAVE A COLLECTION SYSTEM IN
PLACE AND THEY WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING THE
COST YEAR ON BEHALF OF ALL
OTHER LINES OF BUSINESS.
MEDICARE. MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS.
OCULAR THEY WOULD HAVE TO. ON
THE FACILITY. THAT WHICH
ALTHOUGH THE- DOES THE REALLY.
IN A- SAVINGS AND- BETTER
MARKET SYSTEM PRODUCTIVE
ACTUALLY ACT. TO THE CHIEF. YOU
WILL NOW HAVE LOCAL INTO THE
DOING THE SAME WORK I'M GOOD TO
ASK YOU TO ALL THE- WRAP UP IF
YOU COULD. OF COURSE OF COURSE.
I'M OUR CONCERN ABOUT THE MOST
RECENT ARE CHANGING OPERATIONAL
DATE UNTIL THAT MAY CAUSE SOME
CONFUSION AND FOR THE- REASONS
WE ARE. ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY NOW IF WE
CAN GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWO
IF IT THE ANYBODY. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF. SB TWO FIFTY.
SEEING NOBODY THERE. MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE QUEUE THE
LINE FOR PEOPLE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT FOR PIC PLEASE. ARRIVE
OPPOSITION- SB TWO FIFTY.
HENLEY GERMAN FURIN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OTHERS THE
TWO FIFTY. THE FIRST MOVED TO
LINE SIXTY ONE LINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- I
APOLOGIZE THAT THIS CALL LONDON
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS WILL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ACTUALLY
SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST ONE
REGISTER THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. I COULD TRY
FOR OTHER OPPOSITION MODERATOR.
BUT ONE CHAMPION OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WILL MOVE
TO NUMBER FORTY SIX FORTY SIX
WEEKS AGO AT. THE MANAGER
MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
APP AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS- WOULD ECHO COMIC WITH
CAPTAIN OUTLOOK WE ARE CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO
TO NUMBER FIFTY TWO FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER THIRTY SIX THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE MANAGER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WILL BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS NOW AND I'LL
JUST SAY. DR PAN I APPRECIATE
THIS BILL AND I KNOW. THIS IS
AN ATTEMPT AT THIS WHERE YOU'RE
WORKING ON THIS- BUT I CAN I
KNOW THIS WILL STREAMLINE
THINGS FOR PHYSICIANS. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU AS A AS A CARE
GIVER IT ALSO STREAM THINGS
STREAMLINE THINGS FOR FAMILIES.
HI I CAN'T TELL YOU HAVE TO
HAVING A SICK PERSON IN YOUR
FAMILY I CAN'T TELL YOU THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES TO
PROVIDE THE RESERVATIONS PRIOR
APPROVALS AND THEN TO GET THE
APPOINTMENT. IT IS HARD ENOGH
TO HAVE SOME PRISON HEALTH CARE
ISSUES WITHOUT HAVING TO
STRUGGLE THROUGH THE INSURANCE
PROCESS AS WELL SO ANYTHING
THAT STREAMLINES I THINK IS A
REALLY GOOD IDEA WE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY. OTHER MEMBERS IN
THE ROOM. XIFAXAN A REVIEW FOR.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR GIVING
THIS OPPORTUNITY WILL FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
HOW DOCTOR BRENNER HAS ARE YOU
SPEND QUALITY TIME DISCUSSING
THIS ISSUE WITH ME SO I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU TECH TO
EDUCATE ME AND WALKING THROUGH
THE PROCESS BUT I WANT TO
ADDRESS ALL SEVERAL OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE DISCUSSED WITH
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION OF ONE
BEING THAT- AND I WANT TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTSON PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REFORMS- ARE
CAUSING THE POSSIBILITY OF
FRAUD AND ABUSE AND JUGGLING ON
TRACK FOR TWO YEARS- BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THEY CANNOT HAVE
AUDITS. CAN YOU DRESS UP FOR ME
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
BEFORE- A PHYSICIAN CAN GET-
THIS- COCOA CALLED THE GOLD
CARD OR THE- THEY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY PROVE THEMSELVES THAT
THEY HAVE NOT- THE DATE-%
BASICALLY DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
ARE GETTING HIGH RATES OF
APPROVAL WITH INSTANT TWO
STANDARD DEVIATIONS SO WITH OUR
STATE. WITHIN THE NORM THEY HAD
THAT SHOW THAT THEY ARE GOOD
ACTORS THAT THEY'RE NOT ONES TO
ENTER PROBABLY ORDER-
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRESCRIPTIONS
OR- PERFORM SERVICES THAT HAVE
REQUIRED. A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM THE PLANNED SO THEY HAVE
TO DEMONSTRATE FIRST THAT THEY
ARE- YEAH RESPONSIBLE THAT
THERE AND IF THEY DON'T THEN
THEY DON'T GET THIS RIGHT SO
NOW IT'S THE FAN CAN CONTINUE
CONTINUE TO SCRUTINIZE. AND
THEN AGAIN AFTER THE TWO YEARS
THE PLAN CAN LOOK AGAIN AND SEE
WHAT THEIR BEHAVIOR IS. AND
CERTAINLY UP PLANS- THROUGH THE
CLAIMS DATA ACTUALLY COLLECT A
LOT OF INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE PHYSICIANS A
CONTRACT WITH- DAY AND- SO IT
IS SO THEY DO HAVE THE OPTION
TO AUDIT. AS WELL AND THEY CAN
ALSO LOOK AT THOSE PATTERNS AND
THEY CAN COME BACK AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT. ACTUALLY EVEN THOUGH
HE ORIGINALLY WERE A GOOD ACTOR
YOUR NOW. SOME OF YOUR
PORTANTINO CLAIMS PATTERNS
LOOK- KIND OF THE- SERVING IN
WE DID AN AUDIT WE FOUND THAT
THERE'S PATTERNS THAT WE THINK
WE NEED TO NOW MONITOR YOU AND
NOW YOU'RE BACK ON PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. SO THERE IS THIS
MECHANISM IN PLACE. BECAUSE A
PHYSICIAN HAVE TO DENNIS IT
WOULD NOT BE ANY PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS. RIGHT AND
THERE'S A PLACE FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS BUT I THINK AS
A- SERVER ADMIN MENTIONED AND
ALSO SOMETHING. FOR MY
COLLEAGUES- WHEN WE USE IT IN A
BLANK AWAY. IT STOPS BEING A
TOOL TO. REDUCE FRAUD AND
INAPPROPRIATE ORDERING IT. NOW
BECOMES ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
THAT ACTUALLY INHIBITS PEOPLE
FROM GETTING CARE. AND ACTUALLY
AND EVEN THE LAZY CARE. THANK
YOU THERE'S ONE MORE- ISSUE
THAT I WANT TO DRESS AS I HEARD
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION STATE
AND JUST WANT TO GET YOUR-
FEEDBACK ON THIS THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT THAT THE REFORM A
SHIFTING THAT COST SHARING
COLLECTION RESPONSIBLY TO THE
HEALTH PLANS. ARE WILL MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO COLLECT. AT
EIGHT PM ON THE BACKEND CAN YOU
SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE PLACED HER
WELL FIRST OF ALL IF-
COLLECTING IS DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
IT IS FOR A PHYSICIAN'S
PRACTICE VERSUS THE PLAN THAT
ACTUALLY IS A NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS HAVE TO COLLECT
PAYMENTS INCLUDING PREMIUMS.
FROM PEOPLE SO IN OTHER WORDS-THEY HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO COLLECT PAYMENTS FROM- THEIR
BENEFICIARIES- SO LET'S KEEP
THAT IN MIND. WHEN WE THEN.
PUSH THAT ON TO THE PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES THEN WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT ACTUALLY DOES
MORE FRAGMENTATION WRITERS
OFTENTIMES MORE CONFUSION SO
INSTEAD OF GETTING ONE.
CAUTIONARY STATEMENT FROM YOUR
PLAN YOU NOW GET BECAUSE YOU
SAW TWO DIFFERENT DOCTORS TO
GET TWO DIFFERENT STATEMENTS TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF PEOPLE
CALLING YOU TRYING TO CHASE YOU
DOWN FOR YOUR PAYMENT. AND IN
FACT IN MANY TIMES- PHYSICIANS.
THIS GIVE UP TO COLLECT THE
COST SHARE- BECAUSE IT'S JUST
SO ADMINISTRATIVELY COSTLY AND
DIFFICULT AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY
HAVE TO SPEND WHICH IS BY THE
WAY THE LESS EFFICIENT WHEN
YOU'RE SMALLER SCALE SO THE
PLAN HAS A LARGER. SCALE TO
BILL DO THE STUDENTS BY THE
NORMAL COURSE OF USINESS
ANYWAY WHEN EXPECTING TO DO
ANYTHING. THEY DON'T. ALREADY
DO WE JUST COLLECT MONEY. FROM
PEOPLE OUT FROM FROM
BENEFICIARIES. SO I THINK THAT
IS AGAIN A WAY TO SIMPLIFY
STREAMLINE AND REALLY ACTIONS
MORE ON THE PATIENT AND- IN
TERMS OF LESS CONFUSION TOO
BECAUSE THEY WILL SEE MULTIPLE
PROVIDERS AND THEN EACH
PROVIDER IF THERE HAD EXPECTING
COLLECTOR OWN COST SHARED INTO
GOING TO GET. INDIVIDUAL LITTLE
THINGS. AND SOMETIMES THERE'S
CONFUSION ABOUT. DIFFERENT
THINGS ESPECIALLY YEAH WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT CAPS AND
DEDUCTIBLES AND SO FORTH- EACH
INDIVIDUAL PERSON AT THE
PROVIDERS TRYING TO COLLECT
THE- CASHIER BUT THEN THE
LARGER ONE IS OF COURSE.
MANAGED BY THE PLANET SATURN SL
I THINK IT MAKES MORE SENSE.
FOR PLANS TO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT
THESE FUNCTIONS IN ASKING
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS TO IRISH
ALSO MENTIONED THAT- THE
OPPOSITION MENTION FOR EXAMPLE
MEDIC CAL. THOSE OF US TO KNOW
MEDIC HOUSE- THERE'S VERY
MINIMAL COST SHARING INVOLVED
IN ACCOUNT FACT THAT. ZERO YOU
INTO IT AND SO- I DON'T THINK
THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL. BURDEN ON
THAT THAT AND- THANK YOU AND I
JUST HAVE ONE. YOU PER ADDRESS
IT BECAME SHARE THE INPUT.
TIMELINE SURE- SO AGAIN THIS
IS- THE IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE
IS SO BASICALLY- I WANT TO GET
THROUGH THE NEMESIS HERE SO
BASICALLY OF I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION BY THE WAY- SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- GIVING THEM
UNTIL DO YOU MAY SEE A CD I
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
DEVELOP THEIR METHODOLOGY AND
THEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE IS-
WHEN. THEY ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
ME THESE THESE ITEMS I SHOULD
MENTION THAT- FUND OPPOSITION
POINTS IS THAT WHAT WE'RE BUILT
IN COLLECTION COSTS AT CENTER
AND TO OUR CONTRACTS WELL IF
THIS BILL PASSES AND IS SIGNED
INTO LAW IT WILL BE TIME FOR
THEM TO RE NEGOTIATE CONTRACTS
AND- THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
PLANS DO WITH PHYSICIANS. YOU
KNOW THEY MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE CONTRACTS. YEAH I SAID ALL
THE TIME BUT AT LEAST ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS- SO THAT THEY
COULD OFTEN MAKE DEPENDING ON
CHANGING ENVIRONMENTAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SO EARLY THAT
WOULD BE A POINT OF- RE
NEGOTIATION. WITH WITH PLANS- I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT WOULD
ALREADY DOING A LOT OF
RENEGOTIATION RELATED TO COVE
IT WITH PLANS AND PAYMENTS AND
SO FORTH- TO TRY TO DRESS ME
THE SHOULD HAVE COME UP WITH A
CRISIS AS WELL. PRESHEAF THE
DETAILED EXPLANATION THAT WILL
BE ALL THANK YOU. SENATE ROTH-
THANK YOU- I GUESS SO MELCHER.
OF YOU KNOW I TOOK A LOOK AT
THIS AND I WILL I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT I UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M DOING WHEN I VOTE TO
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT I CAN
EXPLAIN MY POSITION TO THOSE
WHO. MAY BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BILL IN THE DISTRICT OR
OTHERWISE OR CERTAINLY THOSE
WHO HAVE OBJECTIONS TO THE BILL
AND IT OCCURRED TO ME THAT THE
REAL RELATIONSHIP HERE WHEN IT
COMES TO HEALTH INSURANCE IS
BETWEEN THE PATIENT TO CONSUMER
AND THE PLAN WITH A HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN IS SECURED. AND
THEN WELL THERE BE MAYBE
ISSUES- EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL
THAT NEED TO BE WORKED ON AND
WORKED OUT AS IT MOVES OUT OF
THIS CHAMBER TO. OF THE OTHER
CHAMBER AND TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK FOR SIGNATURE- IT SEEMED
TO ME AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT IT CERTAINLY MAKES SENSE
IS THE AUTHOR INDICATED FOR THE
PLAN TO LOOK TO. THE CONTRACT
BENEFICIARY. FOR THE PAYMENT
OF- DEDUCTIBLE OR WHATEVER AND
NOT TO TRY TO CHASE DOWN.
INDIVIDUAL PHYSICIANS AND
OTHERS WHO WERE ATTEMPTING
SIMPLY TO ATTEMPTING TO PROVIDE
SERVICE- UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THAT- OF THAT HEALTH PLAN SO
I'LL BE VOTING I TODAY AND I
THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL AND-
THANK YOU OTHER FOR PURSUING IT.
THANK YOU CENTER. SEEING NO
FURTHER IS THERE A CERTAIN.
CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU ARE ON
A BANK- THE MEASURE FOR WATER
IN THIS BILL AND HAPPY TO BE A
CO AUTHOR OF IT AND I AGREE
THAT- PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS TO
HAVE THEIR PLACE IN MADISON AND
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US IS
BEGRUDGING THE HEALTH PLANS
FROM HAVING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS BUT ON THE CIVIC
THEY'VE GONE TOO FAR AND I
THINK WHAT USED TO BE THE
EXCEPTION IS. A TIMES
INCREASINGLY BECOMING THE RULE-
AND WE'VE SEEN- WHAT THEY CAN
DO SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU MAY
RECALL COLLEAGUES A FEW YEARS
AGO AND LEGISLATION TO AND
AMONG OTHER THINGS AND- PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR PROP AND PAP
ANTI HIV. OR AIDS OR HIV
PREVENTION DRUGS. WERE WE WERE
SEEING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION SO.
WHICH OF THE LADY AND HAVING.
THIS MEDICINE CAN ACTUALLY MEAN
YOU GET HIV SO OVER THE DOCTOR
DETERMINES THAT YOU ARE AT RISK
FOR HIV THEY WANT TO GET YOU ON
PROP IMMEDIATELY. AND THEN AS A
ONE MONTH OR TWO MONTHS LATER
FIGHT WITH THE INSURANCE
COMPANY. THERE WERE THERE EVEN
WAS EVEN INSURANCE COMPANY THAT
WAS TRYING TO IMPOSE A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. FOR PAT WHICH IS
WHEN YOU THINK YOU'VE BEEN
EXPOSED AND YOU MUST TAKE THE
MEDICINES. STARTING WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS AND THE
SOONER THE BETTER. AND SO. THE
OF THE X. THAT WE'VE SEEN. I
HAD A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE FROM
MY DOCTOR FOR CONDITION I HAVE
PRESCRIBED PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE MEDICINE.
IMMEDIATELY OF INSURANCE
COMPANY REJECTED THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND SAID I HAD A
STORE ON A COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE MEDICINE THAT I
WOULD HAVE REFUSED TO TAKE. MY
DAUGHTER TO SPEND HOURS. ON THE
PHONE ESCALATING- UNTIL HE
FOUND A POSITION. WORKING FOR
THE PLAN HE SAID OF COURSE HE
SHOULD GET THOSE. ON MEDICINE.
SERVICES PLAYING OUT EVERY DAY
AND I HAD THIS LEGISLATION
TAKES A REALLY BALANCED
APPROACH OF A PHYSICIAN'S.
BETTER YOU'RE BEING REASONABLE
AND NOT BEING- BUSIVE THAN
THEY CAN OPERATE IN A
STREAMLINED WAY AND NOT BE
CONSTANTLY SECOND GUESSED. IN
THEIR. JUDGEMENTS FIRES IN
IDAHO. WITH THAT THE EMOTION
SILVA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DR PAN
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA CONFIRM
I DO NOT SEE ANY RAISE YOUR
HANDS BECAUSE I'M THE ONE WHO
CAN SEE IT YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
CAN SO- ANYONE ON REMOTELY WANT
TO SEE ANYTHING DON'T SEE
ANYONE JUST WANNA CONFIRM.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AT- MET CENTER AGONUM
EGGMAN- THIS IS REALLY ABOUT-
TRYING TO REDUCE
INEFFICIENCIES- LET'S HAVE THE
BLUETOOTH CONFUSION FOR
PATIENTS LET'S HAVE DOCTOR
BILLS AND A LITTLE MORE TIME
ACTUALLY MEETING WITH THEIR
PATIENTS- I SIMPLY WANT TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW
THERE'S A PLACE FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION WE'RE NOT SAYING
WE WANT TO LIMITED
PRIORITIZATION WE'D CERTAINLY
WANT TO BE SURE PEOPLE GET THE
RIGHT CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME-
THAT E DO NOT WANT TO HAVE
INAPPROPRIATE CARE SO CERTAINLY
WANT TO. WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S BETTER
WAYS TO GO ABOUT DOING IT
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS AND SO FORTH
BUT I THINK THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES AND UNDERLYING THIS
BILL I HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
IS THAT IF SOMEONE'S BEEN. A
YOU KNOW BEEN A GOOD ACTORS ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING- LET'S
NOT MAKE THEM KEEP HAVING TO GO
THROUGH HOOPS AND HOOPS AND
HOOPS JUST TO TRY TO DELIVER
THE RIGHT CARE TO PATIENTS
LET'S NOT MAKE PATIENTS HAVE TO
WAIT AND WAIT AND WAIT SO THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE RIGHT CARE
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IN THE- IS PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. PAN PAN AYE
MELENDEZ. EGGMAN BY EGGMAN I
CAN SALAS HI. GONZALEZ I GREW-
TATO MY POTATO I LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LIMóN. BETTER LIMóN SP
TWO FIFTY HI. WOMEN ARE AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE. THAT
THAT BILL IS NINE ZERO WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN FOR CHAIRING I KNOW IT'S
A LITTLE CHALLENGING BEING DOWN
THERE AND I'M UP HERE SO I CAN
STILL SEE EVERYTHING SO
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH ME
MAKING THAT WORK- AND THANK YOU
FOR SO MUCH FOR TAKING ON THE
GAVEL HERE. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
THREE FORTY NINE BY CENTER
NUMBERED CASEY CENTER NUMBER
HERE WELCOME- PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU AND- ESPECIALLY
YOUR STAFF MEMBER RAISE THE IS
FOR. YOUR HARD WORK IN
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL THE
CALIFORNIA ETHICAL TREATMENT.
FOR PERSONS WITH ADDICTION ACT
STORE PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS FROM
UNSCRUPULOUS SERVICE PROVIDERS
BY ENSHRINING IN LAW. A SERIES
OF COMMONSENSE RIGHTS BY
PROHIBITING DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISING MARKETING PRACTICES
TO KEEP THESE VULNERABLE PEOPLE
FROM GETTING THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED FOR MEDICAL. PROVIDERS
LEGISLATURES MAKE GREAT STRIDES
TOWARDS PROTECTING.
CALIFORNIANS SEEM CARE FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES FILE
LONG ABUSE OF ABUSE ABUSIVE
PATIENT BROKERING PRACTICES
THAT THRIVE. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S REHAB RIVIERA THIS
BILL IS MODELED ON- A- LET THE
LATEST VOEPEL THE NATIONAL. FOR
MODEL STATE DRUG LAWS THE
BUILDS UPON THAT WORK- WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS THIS BILL
PROVIDES A LIST OF RIGHTS TO
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING
TREATMENT. AND ALSO PROVIDES A
PENALTY FOR PROVIDING FALSE OR
MISLEADING INFORMATION- AYE
ORIGIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER- BURKE- LET'S NOW TAKE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- SO WE DO
HAVE SIDE LEVY OF ONE WITNESSES
WHOSE TESTIFYING SUPPORT THAT'S
JERRY DALY- WITH THE CONSORTIUM
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS SO- MODERATE TO
COMPLETE PLEASE BRING HER ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY. AND SURE
DALY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR
NUMBER SHERRY DALY CITY
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING
ADDICTION COUNSELORS COULDN'T
PROGRAMS RECOVERY RESOLUTION
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN RECOVERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR WE
COULD FORTY NINE AND CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE DANGEROUS AND
DESPICABLE PRACTICE OF
ADDICTION PATIENT BROKERING
THAT STILL PLAGUES OUR STATE
AND MUST BE ADDRESSED. ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE SPONSORED SEVERAL
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS AREA SO
CALLED ADDICTION TREATMENT
REGISTRIES OR ONLINE SCAM
WEBSITES THAT REDIRECT LOCAL
CLIENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS TO
UNSCRUPULOUS MARKETERS. TELL
PATIENTS TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER
ARE STILL OPERATING WITH
IMPUNITY THEY REMAIN DIFFICULT
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO ADDRESS
GIVEN OUR CURRENT STATUTES. YOU
MA'AM HOW DO I KNOW THESE
ENTITIES ARE SUFFERING UPON
PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION WELL I
ACTUALLY GOOGLED A LEGITIMATE
PROGRAM I KNOW. TO PROVIDE
EXCELLENT SERVICE THE MODESTO
CALIFORNIA AND THE FIRST YEAR
ON MY GOOGLE SEARCH OR A
BEAUTIFUL PICTURE OF THAT
FACILITY ITS STAFF AND SERVICES
BUT WHEN I CLICKED ON IT I WAS
SENT TO A WEB PAGE NOT
BELONGING TO THAT PROGRAM AND
FOUND MYSELF IMMEDIATELY
CONNECTED TO A PATIENT RECORDS.
CONDITION A HARD TOKEN TEAM
THAT INCLUDED THREATS. THAT THE
PRETEND YOUNG ADULT I WAS
CALLING ABOUT WOULD BE DEAD BY
SUNDAY IF I DIDN'T MORTGAGE MY
HOUSE AND LOOK FOR HER TO A
TREATMENT PROGRAM IN MICHIGAN
BY FRIDAY HE NEVER ONCE ASKED
ABOUT MY PUT TEN DOLLARS
CONDITION IF YOU WOULD NEED A
DETOXIFICATION. WHAT YOUR
SYMPTOMS WORK IF HE MIGHT BE
SUICIDAL HE SIMPLY WANT TO KNOW
WHAT MY INSURANCE WAS HER AGE
AND HER DRUG OF CHOICE SEVEN
WHEN I DID MANAGE TO BE
CONNECTED TO THE TREATMENT
PROGRAM. I HAD CALLED ABOUT HE
DISCREDITED IT AT OUR STATE IN
GENERAL OR BOB MY DAUGHTER AND
THEN REFUSED TO CONNECT YOU TO
THE PROGRAM THE STILL LOOKS
BRAND NEW BILLION. PARTISAN
LOCAL LA ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO REMOVE ARE LEGITIMATE
PROVIDERS FROM THESE SCAMS AND
INSTAGRAM JUST WHEN THEY ARE
FOUND TO OCCUR IT ALSO CREATES
FIRST STATE THE STATE'S FIRST
EVER PATIENT CELEBRATE. FOR
PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE I SUPPORT I.
STARTED THINKING. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
ARTISTS MODERATOR. WE PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB.
THREE FORTY NINE. IN LATE IN
GERMANY PRINT SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE FORTY NINE. EDUCATE
OUT MODERATELY JUST TO PUT HIM
ON POLICIES FOR A QUICK MOMENT
DON'T THEM GOT OFF THE PHONE-
CENTER NUMBER DID YOU WISH TO.
SAY SOMETHING- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS. I WAS ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT MISS
MICHELLE. OR BY ERIC OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE FOR MODEL
STATE DRUG LAWS OF SHE'S ON.
AMID HER TWO MINUTES TO TOUCH
OUR SORRY APOLOGIZE SHE WASN'T
ON MY LIST BUT WHAT'S HER NAME
AGAIN YOU SAID. MISS MICHELLE
WORRELL BAYEK OKAY IS THERE
MICHELLE WORLD BY IT COULD BE A
LITTLE ON THE- PHONE LINES
APOLOGIZE FOR THIS MODERATOR.
HUH YES. ONE IS OPEN. OKAY
SORRY FUTURE IS ON THE LIST
OKAY THANK YOU SO I APOLOGIZE
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBER I AM
MICHELLE BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE FOR MODEL
STATE DRUG ALIVE AND IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
NINE. WHICH CREATES A RANGE YOU
WILL TREATMENT FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS AND PROTECTION
FROM PREDATORY PRACTICES THAT
THREATEN ACCESS TO THIS
LIFESAVING EFFECTIVE TREATMENT.
I NEED TO CONTINUE TO FACE A
GROWING SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
EPIDEMIC THAT HAS BEEN GREATLY
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ONE ONGOING
BARRIER TO ACCESSING QUALITY
TREATMENT IS THE PROLIFERATION
OF PREDATORY AND UNETHICAL
PRACTICES. WHICH WE THOUGHT
ABOUT THE WAR THAT SEVERAL
YEARS AGO IN TWENTY NINETEEN
MAN STILL PARTNERED WITH.
ARNOLD VENTURES TO ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS. IN OUR WORKING THE
CLAIM REMOTE AND TO I'M AT THE
BUSINESS BY. STATEMENTS OF
COMMERCE JUST. BY THE- AND
THEIR PRO. THE BUSINESSES
PROVIDED LITTLE OR NO TREATMENT
ONCE PAYMENT SOURCES DRIED UP
INDIVIDUALS WERE RELEASED TO
RELAPSE ONCE AGAIN OR WORSE.
NANCIAL DEVELOPED THE MODEL
PAGE TO PROTECTION AND
TREATMENT AT THE ACT TO ADDRESS
THE PRACTICES HEAD ON. SENATOR
BURKE FINALLY CRAFTED SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY NINE TALK FOR
FREE HE PORTIONS OF THE MODEL
I. WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FORTUNATE TO HAVE
MANY EXCELLENT ADDICTION
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND ALSO HAS
A DISTILLATION OF PLACE TO
DISCOURAGE PREDATORY PRACTICES.
INCLUDING BURBANK LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND A PROHIBITION
OF KICKBACKS FOR REFERRALS.
WHAT THE PLACE AN AD IT CLIENT
TREATMENT BILL OF RIGHTS.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO TRUTHFUL
TREATMENT INFORMATION
INDIVIDUALIZED EVIDENCE BASED
CARE PLANNING SERVICES BY A
WHITE ST AND CERTIFIED
PROFESSIONAL. SAFE AND ETHICAL
TREATMENT SETTING AND TREATMENT
FOR CO OCCURRING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS WHICH ARE
COMMON. BY LEESON CAN NOW BE
ADDRESSED TO THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW ACTION BY THE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR TO THE
DEPARTMENT. IT WAS NEEDED TO
CREE A LEVEL PLAYING THAT
ECONOMIC. THE PROBE AND
PERSONNEL ENGAGE AND OR SOME
HOW DID I'M- AND UNETHICAL.
PLEASE READ MA'AM TOLD.
SUPPORTS SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY NINE TO DETER AND PUNISH
UNETHICAL PREDATORY ACTORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MICHELLE WERE
BACKED UP I APOLOGIZE TO YOU
AND CENTER OF BURKE ACTUALLY
AYE AYE AND CERTAINLY SKIPPED
OVER HER NAME IN THE LIST MY
STAFF THAT HAVE IT ON THERE- SO
MY APOLOGIES- MODERATOR LET'S
NOW MOVE BACK TO TELEPHONIC
LINE AND AGAIN. WE PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY NINE. ABSOLUTELY AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FORTY NINE. PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FORTY NINE. WELL FIRST GO
TO NUMBER SIXTY SIX SIXTY SIX
COULD GO AT. HI THIS IS ANY
ENTITLED WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FORTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONE
SENATOR IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU MODERATOR
NOW LOVE TO MOVE TO OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE FORTY NINE- I GOING
TO THE GALLERY IS KNOWN IN THE
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SAY NO AND IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S NOW-MOVE TO OUR TELEPHONIC SERVICE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FORTY
NINE. IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE FORTY NINE. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU
THAT'S NOW TAKE IT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THIS IS A GOOD
COMMON SENSE BILL THAT WILL
PROTECT VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO NOT ONLY
MOVES THE BILL INAPPROPRIATE
BUT ALSO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO BILLS- BUT WE KNEW
THAT THE PREPPY THOMAS AND
RUBIO OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NINE SEEING NO
HANDS UP- SAMBERG A. I. TWO ONE
TWO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD DRESSING A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE BE SURE THAT WE
HAVE FULL DISCLOSURE FOR PEOPLE
SEEKING THE SERVICES. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THOSE WHO SADLY ARE ADDICTED.
RECEIVE RESPONSIBLE CARE AND
THIS BILL HELPS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY DO ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER NUMBER AT THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SARAH RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SECRETARIES CALL THE
ROLL PAN HI. CAN I MELINDA'S.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE AND SALAS
GONZALEZ MICRO FURTADO HURTADO
I'D. LEYVA LEYVA EILEEN MON.
THEN EARLY LOAN IT SB THREE
FOUR NINE HI LIMóN HI ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO RUBIO HI WIENER
WIENER NAY. OKAY THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES- WILL
KEEP THE BILL- ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
NUMBER. RIGHT FINALLY WE ARE AT
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B.
TWO TWENTY ONE FOR SIR WE DON'T
DO A PRESENT YOUR DESKS ARE
WIENER. THAT'S JUST. EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW CODE NOT SPREAD
BY. CONTACT AS MUCH AS WE
THOUGHT BEFORE BUT BIGELOW TO
MINIMIZE AS I SPEAK TO TWENTY
ONE BY CENTER WIENER- FLEET
PLEASE BEGIN. MY MICROPHONE
ALWAYS FALLS. BY THE HEAD OF
THE THREE TRAINED UP- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR- WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE IN THIS BILL
WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON- THE
PAGE OF THE ANALYSIS OF THANK
YOU- SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
ONE- WILL ESTABLISH CLEAR A
TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS FOR
FOLLOW UP CARE NEEDED BY
PATIENTS- TO TREAT MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. THE BILL CLOSE A
CLOSE THE CRITICAL LOOPHOLE IN
THE FIFTH TIMELY ACCESS
REGULATIONS- BY ENSURING ABOUT
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
PROVIDE PATIENTS WITH FOLLOW UP
CARE WITHIN TEN BUSINESS DAYS
ADDRESSING WIDESPREAD LINKING
THE LAYS. FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE. CURRENTLY ARE
FOR. SPECIFIED APPOINTMENTS
WITH A MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
PROVIDER. MUST OCCUR WITHIN TEN
BUSINESS DAYS- BY ONLY APPLY
THAT TO INITIAL APPOINTMENTS
BUT NOT TO FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS. SO AND PRACTICES
AMBIGUITY. RESULT IMPATIENCE TO
GET A PROMPT FIRST VISIT. FOR
THE MISS SUBSEQUENT VISITS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY. DELAYED WITHOUT
THAT TIMELY FOLLOW UPON MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT. OF PATIENTS
CAN- REALLY BETTER THEIR
RECOVERY CAN BE DELAYED FOR THE
NOT OUT IN A TIMELY CARE THE
BAY. NEED THIS IS IN AN
INCREASE MORBIDITY AND
MORTALITY RATES INCREASE TIME
AWAY FROM WORK AS A HAVE A
DELAYED RECOVERY INCREASE
STRAIN ON FAMILIES AND
ACCELERATING CRISES REQUIRING
MORE COSTLY AND INTENSIVE.
INTERVENTIONS PROVEN NINETEEN
IS MAKING WHAT WAS ALREADY A
BAD MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE CRISIS MUCH WORSE WE SEE
THAT FROM SURVEY AFTER SURVEY
AFTER SURVEY NOW MORE THAN
EVER. PEOPLE NEED TIMELY ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
TREATMENT SB TWO TWENTY ONE- IS
A MEANINGFUL CHANGE- VERY
TECHNICAL BUT IT IS MEANINGFUL
AND ILL ENSURE THE PEOPLE GOT
MORE TIMELY CARE. WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IF CHELSEA
MARTINEZ AS A MOTHER OF TWO IN
THE NORTH BAY. WHO HAS RECEIVED
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FROM
KAISER AND FROM OTHER
PROVIDERS. AND SUSAN WHITNEY
WHO IS A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST. FROM
BAKERSFIELD W. TESTIFIED OF
WERE ALSO JOINED NOT FOR
TESTIMONY ABOUT FOR MY
ANSWERING POTENTIAL QUESTIONS
BY A PAUL KUMAR WHO'S WITH OUR
SPONSORS THE NATIONAL UNION. OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR WE NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO IN SUPPORT- SO MODERATOR
CAN BRING ON THE LINE THE FIRST
CHELSEA MARTINEZ. AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY SUSAN WHITNEY EACH
WITNESS YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY. SO FIRST
LET'S BEGIN WITH CHELSEA
MARTINEZ- HI MY NAME IS CHELSEA
I'M THIRTY SIX YEAR OLD MOTHER
OF TWO. I AM DIAGNOSED WITH
MAJOR DEPRESSIVE DISORDER
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND BORDERLINE PERSONALITY
DISORDER I THANK NINETY ONE I
BECAME A PATIENT OF HAVE BEEN
AROUND TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD.
HI THERE FOR ONE ON ONE THERAPY
I WOULD TYPICALLY SIXTY BETWEEN
APPOINTMENTS SOMETIMES LONGER.
WAIT THAT LONG I DID NOT GET
BETTER IN FACT IT MADE THINGS
MUCH WORSE FOR ME. WHENEVER I
WOULD MEET WITH A THERAPIST
AFTER SUCH A LONG BREAK I WOULD
HAVE TO REINTRODUCE MYSELF IN
TWENTY THREE. I WOULD HAVE TO
RE OPEN MY ROOM EVERY TIME AND
I. HAD NO GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
KILL THEM. THE FIRST MINUTES
COULD BE PICKING UP. AT TAKEN
UP BY RE INTRODUCING MYSELF AND
PARLIAMENTARY. AND IT WAS
ALMOST NO TIME BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN CURRENTLY IN
MY LIFE AND CERTAINLY NOT
ENOUGH TIME. TO HELP YOU MANAGE
ALL THE EMOTIONS THE TRAUMA BY
COULD JUST IT. AFTER THE
SESSION MY CLASS BECAME MOST OF.
I WOULD EXPECTED AT THAT THE
MOVIES. HOURS SOMETIMES DAYS.
COULD RECALL IN ABOUT IT. I
STARTED CONTENT. WITH I'M A
FROM THE DAY BASIS. WHEN I WAS
THIRTY I STARTED PAYING OF
POCKET TO GET THEIR PETS OUT OF
HI THERE WHICH CREATED EXTREME
HARDSHIP MY AT THE TIME. THANK
AND I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET WITH
ABOUT LINE HILL. THE FIRST SIX
WEEKS HAVE AT LEAST WEEK PARENT
I CRITICAL ON HERE. HI I
HAVEN'T WITH THE AS THE FIRST
TIME BUT BY SAYING OF MY TRAUMA
COMES BACK. WE REACH OUT TO
MAKE THEIR INDEPENDENT CARE
THAT I. TO LOOK THROUGH IT.
EVEN THAT I HAVE. TO CARE WHEN
I IT MOST ME FEEL EIGHT TO DEAL
MY- I WHAT THE PHRASE HOW. I
ABLE TO MOVE ON WITH THE WHITE
FAMILY COMP AND MORE DID NOT
OWN LIFE. BUT WHAT PROPER TREAT
CAN DO PEOPLE. ANYTHING LIKE
THAT. HOME I THANK YOU FOR
TAKING AFTER ON WHY IT. FOR
MUCH. AND COUNTY OTHERS. THANK
YOU THREE- JUST MARTINEZ NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO WHITNEY. CAN
YOU HEAR ME A YES PLEASE BEGIN.
HI AM PLEASED WHITNEY- LICENSE
IN MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST THAT KIND BECAUSE AND
OF WORKED FOR A THIRTY YEARS
TREATING PATIENTS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM OF MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS. PRIMARILY CHILDREN TEENS
AND FAMILIES OVER MY CAREER
LOCATION BY TREATED HAVE BEEN
ENROLLED IN COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS THAT WOULD BE COVERED
UNDER SB TWO TWO ONE. THE
EXPERIENCE MISS MARTINEZ JUST
DESCRIBED IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT CLINICAL STUDIES TELL US
ABOUT TREATING MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
PATIENTS AREN'T SEEN FREQUENTLY
ENOUGH THEY OFTEN DON'T GET
BETTER. THE TREAD WATER IN
THEIR OWN. SOMETIMES FOR YEARS.
TOO OFTEN THEIR ILLNESSES GROW
WORSE WITH INCREASED MORBIDITY
AND MORTALITY LONGER RECOVERY
TIME MORE TRIPS TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND MORE COSTLY
CARE. THAT'S WHY THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
PRACTICE GUIDELINES RECOMMEND
THAT PATIENTS BE TREATED WEEKLY
FOR MANY COMMON DIAGNOSES SUCH
AS DEPRESSION AND PTSD.
ESPECIALLY AT THE ONSET OF
THEIR CARE. IF PEOPLE TIME
FOLLOW UP CARE MANY MAKE
PROGRESS IN RELATIVELY SHORT
TIME FRAME STABILIZER AND
GRADUATE TO LESS INTENSIVE
TREATMENT. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
PATIENTS DO NOT RECEIVE
FREQUENT ENOUGH FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENT. IN MY CLINIC
PATIENTS WITH DIAGNOSES LIKE
DEPRESSION ANXIETY BIPOLAR
DISORDER AND PTSD TYPICALLY
WAIT FOUR TO EIGHT WEEKS OR
MORE BETWEEN APPOINTMENTS THIS
IS TRUE ACROSS THE STATE HI
THERE CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST HMO.
AND IT'S GETTING WORSE TO THE
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR
ITS BY THE PANDEMIC. FLU CALL
IN CURRENT REGULATIONS
GENERALLY FOCUSES HEALTH PLANS
ATTENTION ON TIMELY ACCESS TO
INITIAL APPOINTMENT BUT NOT TO
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS WITH THE
PREDICTABLE RESULT AT HEALTH
PLANS LIKE KAISER DON'T
PRIORITIZE THE LATTER. THAT'S
WHY I SUPPORT SB TWO TO ONE IT
PASSED IT WILL HELP FOCUS
HEALTH PLANS ON THE CRITICAL
NEED FOR TIMELY FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS WHICH IS ESSENTIAL
FOR ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY. NEED
PAGE EVERYTHING. THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY FOR YOUR CUSTOMER-
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TO ONE OF BEGINNING
IN THE GALLERY SEEN ON THE
GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM%
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING- VIA
TESTIFIED VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORBIS MODERATOR WE PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
TWO ONE. IN LATE GERMAN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO ONE. WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN POINT SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR
PAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS ADRIAN SHELTON REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
MENTAL HEALTH INSTRUCTS THE
PORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AT. MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS BOB LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
SIX OF THE NUMBER SEVENTY
NUMBER SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK IN ADVANCE WITH HEALTH
ACCESS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO TWENTY ONE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND I'M
COMING AND I'M A TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT LINE. NEXT WE NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MELISSA
CORTEZ REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
STATES AND THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM AND RELATED DISORDERS
REPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. NEXT
WE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS HEY IT'S
PAUL YODER- ON BEHALF OF THE
NEWLY FORMED CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT YOU'RE LITERALLY
HELPING MILLIONS CAL. WITH
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS THANK YOU
EXACT MODELING LEGISLATION FOR
OTHER STATES THANK YOU WE'RE
TAKING HIS NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. NEXT LINE PLEASE. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO TWO ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN SUPPORT
PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK YOU
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO. PEOPLE
LISTED TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
BUDGET HAMPTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS AND
STUFF THE WALK INS FROM
DISSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
BOTH ON THE PHONE LINES OF HIM
FOR SPRING ON. GET HAMPTON EACH.
NISKANEN HAVE TWO MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY SO SPIRITED HAMPTON.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE TECHNICAL
CALIFORNIA THIRTY FIVE HEALTH
PLAN- REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE
IN OPPOSITION THAT THE P.
TWENTY ONE THIS AFTERNOON WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
THE FATHER AND THE MANY STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
CELL. I DO WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT WE DO APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF THE BILL AND
AGREE SENATE SHARING ACT THAT
THE KREMLIN. CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH- IT'S
QUITE A- HELLO WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT SB TWENTY ONE. ONE FIVE
IT'S ALL APPROACH TO GET A
FOLLOW UP. WITHIN TEN DAYS.
THEY DID NOT ADEQUATELY
CONSIDER MANY CHALLENGES THAT
THE PRESIDENT SHALL. THE
TYPICALLY THIS BILL DOES NOT
CONSIDER REAL PEOPLE HE MY- I'M
NOT HAD A CALL THAT WILL TEN
CRIME. SAMPLING INDIVIDUALS MAY
NOT FEEL LIKE PROVIDER THE A
PHOTO DETECT WOULD BE INTO THE-MAKING THE THAT THE UPON THEIR
PERSONAL. BY WEEKLY OR MONTHLY
SO ARE. WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
THAT THIS COULD ON IN- THE
PROVIDER NETWORK BY REQUIRING
PLAN DURING FOR OUT OF NETWORK.
IT FOR NOW OPERATE IN THE WHEN.
HOPE FOR DELIBERATELY SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ROBUST NETWORK.
NEEDED MEMBERS. CONSIDER THE
ENORMOUS THAT FOOT BILL PLACES
UPON CONTRA FOR THE- THAT
LITANY OF ALL APPOINTMENTS.
YEAH RIGHT SERVICES OUT OF
NETWORK. A LOT THIS REPORT IS
NOT CAL FIFTEEN CRITICAL OF NEW
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THE DAY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO STUDY
FOUND THAT WITHOUT A THIRD
EFFORT TO RECRUIT RETAIN MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS CALIFORNIA
HAS 50% FEWER PSYCHIATRISTS 30%%
YOU'RE A THERAPIST CAN REPEAT
THE MANTRA BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH
SERVICES BY TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. CALL THE NINETY CAN THEN
I CAN ONLY. THIS REPORT FORTY.
YES AFTER THE THIRD HAVE BEEN
INCREASED. SIMPLY PUT MANDATING
INCREASED THREE OF ABOUT
ADDRESSING WORKFORCE OR COULD
NOT BE ALL YOU CARE RATHER WILL
BE PROVIDER YOU CAN MANAGE
EXISTING CLOSE AND WORK SURE
ENOUGH BUT- IT WILL UP
APPOINTMENT WITHIN THE DAYS
TIME FRAME PROPOSED SENATE BILL.
PRETTY RECENTLY- RESPECTABLE
ANOTHER IRAQI PEOPLE ANYWAY AND
ACCORDING TO WORK WITH THE
OPERA BONTA THE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK THANK YOU KNOW
SPRING ON STEPHANIE. WADKINS
PLEASE. REMEMBER ONE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS AND ALSO
HIGHLIGHT- OUR CONCERN WITH
RESPECT TO THE BILL SEEKING TO
CODIFY A PORTION OF THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS. OPINION YOU
CAN APPRECIATE REGULATIONS
THEY'RE REALLY INTENDED TO GIVE
LIFE TO THE STATUTORY STRUCTURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TAX. THESE
GUIDELINES ARE MORE LIKE LIVING
BREATHING DOCUMENTS THAT ALLOW
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT TO FALL
THIS INDUSTRY'S CHANGING GROW.
AS EXAMPLE COMMITTEE IS A VALUE
WAITING INTERVIEWING THEIR
CURRENT REGULATORY TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS. AS THE GDI
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN THEY
CHOSE INCORPORATED DIGITAL
ACCESS STANDARDS WHICH WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
TRADITIONAL GEO ACTION
STANDARDS THAT EXISTED. AT
LEAST THIRTY CODIFY THE
STANDARDS INTO LAW IT LIMITS
THE OVERSIGHT AND FLEXIBILITY
THE REGULATORS CURRENTLY USED
TO ADDRESS ISSUES AS THEY ARISE
BY SIGNIFICANTLY HINDERING
THEIR ABILITY TO BE NIMBLE. AND
ADDRESS OVERSIGHT ISSUES
QUICKLY SB WOULD NOW BE
REQUIRED TO COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE ANY
MODIFICATIONS NO MATTER HOW
INSIGNIFICANT OUR TECHNICAL
THEY MIGHT BE. JUST TO GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE WE HAVE SEEN OVER
THE LAST YEAR A GREAT DEAL OF
GROWTH IN THE TELE HEALTH
SECTOR. WITH GROWTH COMES THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT THAT COULD BE
HAMPERED IF IT'S FIFTIES
REGULATIONS WERE TO BE ADOPTED
AND STATUES. SURELY IF THE
AUTHORS GOAL AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS ACTIVE IF EXAGGERATE
REQUIREMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND FOLLOW THE POINT
MAN. IT CERTAINLY CAN
ACCOMPLISH THAT WITHOUT TYING
THE HANDS OF THE REGULATORS BY
I'M NECESSARILY CODIFYING
EXISTING TIMELY ACTION
STANDARDS. FOR THESE REASONS
FAMILY REGRETTABLY REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND SPONSORS OF
THE BILLMOVES FORWARD TODAY.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY- NOW WILL
TAKE ON OTHER WE- WHO ARE AND
OPPOSITE. NAME OR- TO. ON A THE
GALLERY C. ON UP IN THE LET'S
TO RUN TWENTY FOUR. SAYING NO
ONE ROOM TO FORTY MOVE TO OUR
TELEPHONIC SERVICE MODERATOR WE
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE SP TWO TWO
ONE. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO TO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
US THE TWO TWO ONE. WELL FIRST
CO TWO LINES SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY APOLOGIES I
MEANT TO GET IN THE SUPPORT
LINE AND COULDN'T- THIS IS
TRULY SNYDER WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MOVED TO NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HOW THEY GOT
THEM BALLOTS WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE SAY NOT IN
OPPOSITION- BUT I KNOW WE'VE
EXPRESSED CONCERN TO MANY OF
THE ON THE BILL REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO APPRECIATE OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE BONKERS FOR
TAKING TIME AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS BUT- THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANKS LINE
PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN SURE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE MR
K. THANK YOU- BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO QUESTION MEMBER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEVEN SAYS THAT
SERGEANTS CAN NOTIFY THE-
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL BE. AFTER YOU CONCLUDE
THIS BILL WILL BE MOVING ON TO
OPENING THE ROLE- AS WELL AS
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE LET THEM KNOW- ARE
THERE QUESTIONS AND COULD I
COME OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. A CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I HEARD
ON THE PLANT'S CORRECTLY I
THINK THEY EXPRESSED CONCERN AT
THE TOP TWO TWO ONE WOULD
INTERFERE WITH A THERAPIST
JUDGMENT ABOUT THE TIMING OF
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS BUT I
THINK IF I READ THE BILL
CORRECTLY ARE EXPLICITLY ALLOWS
BETWEEN APPOINTMENTS FOR ANY
PATIENTS BUT THEY HAVE TO
CERTIFY THAT THE PATIENT'S
HEALTH WON'T SUFFER AS A RESULT
SO I WAS JUST WONDERING IF THE-
OPPOSITION FOR THE PLANS COULD.
INCLUDE JUST EXPLAIN IF THEY
KNEW THAT OR WHY THEY THOUGHT
THAT THAT WOULD INTERFERE OKAY
SO WE CAN BRING IN EITHER JED
HAMPTON OR STEPHANIE WATKINS ON
TO LINE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
FOR CENTER LEYVA. FIND TO
CRITICIZE JEFF HAMPTON ARE YOU
ABLE TO HEAR ME OKAY YES. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION BETTER- IN REFERENCE
TO OUR ARCHIVE MONEY- WE ARE WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT COMPARE TO REQUIRE A
PATIENT MIGHT CHOOSE NOT TO
HAVE A FOLLOW UP VISIT WITHIN
THE TEN DAY TIME FRAME. WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THE BILL
DOES ALLOW FOR- THE CLINICIAN
TO MAKE A JUDGMENT CALL AND
EXTEND THAT TIME FRAME- IF THE-
IF THEY IF THEY SEE THAT AS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PATIENT- YOU KNOW WE COULD
REFERENCE THOUGH ARE AROUND HIM
OF THE FEDERATION ABOUT ONE
INDIVIDUAL OR WORK HE SHOULD
MADE SHOES. I SHOULD NOT HAVE A
FOLLOW UP VISIT WITHIN THE TEN
DAY TIME FRAME TO GET BACK BE
ANYTHING I WANT LINES OF. YOU
KNOW NOT DOING THAT THAT
INITIAL PROVIDER WHO PERFORMED
THE INITIAL DEFINITELY WAS THAT
WITH A GOOD FIT THEM- OR THE
OFFICE WE SPEAK PERSONAL
SCHEDULING. OR OTHER THINGS
THAT THAT COME INTO PLAY- THAT
THAT WOULD ONLY A WHICH WOULD
PREFER THE PATIENT HAVE YOUR
SOMETHING LONGER SO WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT AT THE BILL
DOES PROVIDE. THAT AS THE
CLINICIAN TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION WILL BE ON THE TEN
DAY TIME FRAME- BUT WE ARE. ARE
CONCERNED THAT IT DOES NOT.
SOMETHING- FOR PATIENT TO. THAT
TIME FRAME WHILE. OKAY THANK
YOU HAVE THAT BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
PUBLIC TRAIN. OVER CLOSE SHOULD
BE THE ONE THAT MAKES THAT CALL-
I'VE YOU TALK ABOUT THE WAR
FORCE. BUT I HAVE HEARD OF IT
THERAPISTS SAY THEY DON'T
CONTRACT IN NETWORK WITH HEALTH
PLANS BECAUSE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE TOO LOW A PAYMENT
TIMES ARE TOO LONG AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ARE TOO
GREAT. IF THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGE IS THE MAJOR
IMPEDIMENT TO PROVIDING TIMELY
FOLLOW UP CARE CAN YOU TELL US
SOME STEPS YOU'VE TAKEN TO
BRING MORE LICENSED THERAPIST
IN NETWORK SPECIFICALLY CAN YOU
GIVE US INFORMATION REGARDING
ANY IMPROVEMENTS YOU'VE MADE IN
REIMBURSEMENTS. PAYMENT
PROCEDURES AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROVIDERS. SO IF- MISTER MAGIC
HAMPTON OR STUFFY WALKEN'S-
WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE ANSWER THE
QUESTION. HOME. I THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR THE FOR THE FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER- I WOULD-
YOU KNOW TO GET BACK WOULD HAVE
TO ADD THAT TO THE BACK- IT
DIDN'T GET TOO SPECIFIC FOR YOU
RELATED LOVE THAT THE MORE
SPECIFIC ELEMENT. QUESTION HAS
TO ASK THAT THE BENEFIT TAKEN I
KNOW. WE LOOK- QUITE A BIT
AROUND- THE- THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION FOR A FUTURE REPORT
THAT HAD. THE GAS AND BUT I
THINK. IF YOU ARE OKAY I WOULD
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO- ONCE
AGAIN GO BACK. AND TOUCH BASE
WITH THEM PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FOR YOU
ON THAT QUESTION MOVING
FORWARD. YES THIRTY GREAT I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TO HELP WITH THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGE WE KNOW THAT MENTAL
HEALTH. HAS ALWAYS BEEN
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT IT'S
EVEN MORE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
NOW- I KNEW I WAS ON THE PICKET
LINE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WITH
ARCHITECT FRASER. AND WITH
THEIR THERAPIST BECAUSE THEY
WERE TRYING TO- IMPROVE THE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND ONE OF
THOSE WAS. HER MORE THERAPISTS
SO YES ANY INFORMATION YOU CAN
GIVE ME. REGARDING WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. TO HELP WITH THE
SHORTAGE WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
QUESTIONS ON. OUR COMMENTS ON
SB TWO TWO ONE CENTER GROVE. IT
MAKES SENSE OF THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN I APOLOGIZE GOING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
COMMITTEES AND- I DID AND I AND
I APOLOGIZE IF THIS QUESTION
HAS ALREADY BEEN ASKED AND
ANSWERED- BUT JUST FOR MY
INFORMATION- MY CONCERN THAT I
HAVE WITH THE BILL I GET. I
AGREE THAT WE NEED. A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SPECIALIST
TO BE ABLE TO MEET WITH PEOPLE
IN A TIMELY MANNER. BUT THE
HUGE CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS THE
SHORTAGE OF THE SPECIALIST
AVAILABLE. TO MEET WITH
INDIVIDUALS- IS THERE ANYTHING
IN YOUR BILL- THAT. DEBT IS A
FINE REQUIREMENT- A FINDER'S
FEE. IF THERE ISN'T A REFERRAL
WITHIN THE TEN DAY TIME FRAME
AND THE MAIN REASON I ASK THAT
IS I THINK IT'S NOT RIGHT TO
PUNITIVELY PUNISHED. HEALTH
PLAN. IF THE HAVE A DESIRE TO
REFER PEOPLE TO A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BUT THERE ARE NO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS AVAILABLE. S. AND
WIENER DID YOU WISH TO ADDRESS
THE QUESTION. SURE SO I FIGURED
A QUESTION. SO IF- IF FOR.
HEALTH PLAN. VIOLATES THE LAW.
THERE CAN BE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION. OF A ONE OF THE RIVERS.
AGENCY IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN
TO AND- INSURANCE. TO HELP
THANK REYES WHATEVER DEFENSE.
THAT THEY WON- WE DID HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT- ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH THE MENTAL WORKFORCE- WE
ARE IN BETTER PROBLEM- IT GETS
OVERSTATED AT TIMES- WE DO NEED
TO INCREASE THE WORKFORCE AND I
SEE CENTER AND MENNONITE- AT
OUR NEWLY RECONSTITUTED MENTAL
HEALTH CAUCUS. OR FOCUSING ON
THAT PARTICULARLY FOR NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES-
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES. OUR
DOCTOR TO REYES OVERSTATED AS
AN ISSUE AS AN EXCUSE NOT TO
GIVE GOOD ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT- THE- WE AT
THE PLANS CAN DO BETTER- AND
YOU KNOW THE AND THE LAW HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT. YOU HAVE TO
GIVE IT A POINT WITHIN TEN
BUSINESS DAYS- UNFORTUNATELY
THE REGULATIONS I THINK ARONIE
ISLEY INTERPRETED THAT TO ONLY
APPLY. TO THE FIRST
APPOINTMENT- SO WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR ANYTHING OUTRAGEOUS
HERE WE'RE JUST SAYING. YOU
HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE TO CARE FOR
SICK CONTRACTED- WE WOULD NEVER
AGAIN THIS ALSO GETS INTO
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY. WE WILL
NEVER TOLERATE THIS WITH
PHYSICAL HEALTH AND YET WE DO
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND I YOU
KNOW WE CAN. WE CAN WORK ON
BOTH IN TERMS OF BRINGING MORE
PEOPLE INTO THE PROFESSION BUT
ALSO HAVING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE. HEALTH PLANS TO PROVIDE
TIMELY CARE. THANK YOU APRIL
THAT RISK I DO- I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU KNOW EXACTLY- THE
PHYSICAL CARE COMMENT THAT SHE
MADE ALONG WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH CAUGHT COMMENT BUT- AND
THERE ARE. YOU KNOW MORE
DOCTORS OUT THERE PROVIDING
PHYSICAL CARE THAN THERE ARE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND- I DO YOU
REALLY DO HAVE A CONCERN I
THINK. ESPECIALLY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S RESPONSE TO COVIDIEN
pISOLATED DID THE ISSUES THE
COVERT IS. THE RESPONSE TO CODE
HAS CREATED I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO NEED MORE MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE PROFESSIONALS AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT
YOU KNOW THEY SHOULD GET THE
GET THE PLAN YOU KNOW THAT THE
SERVICES THAT THEY CONTRACTED
IN THE PLAN. AND THAT THEY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OR THEY
PURCHASED FOR THAT PLAN. BUT I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW HOLDING AN
ORGANIZATION ACCOUNTABLE IF
THERE'S IT'S A SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ISSUE FOR ME IF THERE'S
MORE DEMAND AND NOT ENOUGH
SUPPLY. AND HOW DO YOU HOLD
SOMEONE ACCOUNTABLE OR AN
ORGANIZATION ACCOUNTABLE. IF
THEY'RE JUST NOT IF THIRD IF
THE SUPPLY IS NOT THERE. IT WAS
A QUESTION- I KNOW I IT'LL BE A
COMMON I THINK FULL- JUST AFTER
GREETED DISAGREE ON THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT MATTER
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WELL NO BUT YET ANOTHER 1%
GROWTH NO I JUST I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
OF THE BILL FORWARD BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT WE NEED AND- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ESPECIALLY I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A RISE IN THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BUILD ADDRESS
THOSE THINGS. BUT I JUST I
REALLY DO I APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH IT. I JUST IT
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT SO I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS SEEN
NONE I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS UP
EITHER REMOTELY. TAKING ALL
RIGHT. SIR WIENER AYE IT'S
PRETTY YOU BILLING AND BRING
THIS- BILL FORD- I DO WANNA
RECOGNIZE- ACTUALLY CENTER
LEYVA FOR HER LINE OF
QUESTIONING BECAUSE I DO
WORKFORCE RESEARCH AND THAT
SHE'S- LABOR LEADER AND-
SOMETIMES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WORKFORCE OFTENTIMES PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE PIPELINE HOW
MANY PEOPLE TRAINING AND SO
FORTH. BUT I WAS A- HE SAID IT
IN THE END IT'S ABOUT ALSO. IF
YOU ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GO INTO
A PARTICULAR FIELD TO BETTER BE
A GOOD CAREER AT THE END OF IT.
SO IF YOU HAVE A YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET PAID WELL
YOU KNOW I CAN BE TREATED WELL
YOU CAN GET OVERWORKED- PEOPLE.
HE'S YOU CAN TRY TO SHOW PEOPLE
TOWARD TRAINING OUT INTO.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THERE BUT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE THAT
INTERESTED THEY WANT TO KNOW
FROM THE PEOPLE IN THE FIELD
THAT WORKS. SO I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT CERTAINLY I
UNDERSTAND THE- PLANS RAISING
THE ISSUE ABOUT. MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND THAT
THAT THAT CERTAINLY I THINK
THERE'S SOME LEGITIMACY TO THAT
AT THE SAME TIME. I THINK THE
QUESTION THAT CENTER LEYVA
PRODUCT IS ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT SO WHAT HAVE YOU
DONE. IN TERMS OF ON THE LABOR
MARKET SIDE TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT
MORE APPEALING FOR MORE MENTAL
HEALTH. PEOPLE TO GO INTO
MENTAL HEALTH FIELD AND WHEN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PRACTICING.
THE DIGGING PAID AS ARE
DESERVED OR NOT. BEING YOU KNOW
THE OVERHEAD ISN'T. ONEROUS
YOUR WORKING CONDITIONS ARE
ONES WHERE YOU CAN ACTUALLY
FOCUS ON TAKING CARE OF
PATIENTS INSTEAD OF. DOING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK. THINGS
LIKE THAT I'D ALSO POINT OUT
THAT- IN MY ROLE OF OVERSIGHT
OVER THE MEAT C. ON THE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE WE'VE OFTEN HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE NEC THE
HOUSING AND FORCE THE TIMELY
ACCESS RULES. SO THEY'RE NOT
LIKE PICKING UP LIKE- WELL THIS
ONE AND THAT ONE HERE'S A FINE.
LOOKING AT PATTERNS OF BEHAVIOR
IN FACT ACTUALLY OF SOMETIMES
APPEAL TO THEM THEY NEED TO BE
A LITTLE STRICTER ON
ENFORCEMENT- BUT THERE IS YOU
KNOW THEY THEY- DO RECOGNIZE
EVEN WITH THE STANDARDS WE HAVE
EVEN ON PHYSICAL HEALTH- TRYING
TO MAKE THAT WORK AS WELL BUT I
THINK THIS IMPORTANT. MOVE TO
PUSHED AND ACCESS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND CHALLENGE THE-
THE- COVERAGE YOU KNOW THAT
THE- THE FIELD TO TRY TO CREATE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH- PEOPLE CAN
GET MORE TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
AND WITH THAT CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND WIENER. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK. YOU
CALLERS FOR THE STOCK OR
CONVERSATION GEN YOUR I DO JUST
WANNA. THROUGH THING IN TERMS
OF THE WORK. LIKE I SAID WE
WANT TO GET MORE. INTO THE SINK.
IMPORTANT BUT I DO HONESTLY
THINK THAT THE PLANS SOMETIMES
USE OVER STATUS AS AN EXCUSE.
THIS IS A ROBUST. WORK FORCE
AND I THINK THE REIMBURSEMENT
OF THE PARENTS THE PAY IS NOT
GOOD ENOUGH THAT IT DOES THE
SWEET PEOPLE. FROM GOING INTO
IT. ON THE OTHER PIECE OF IT AS
WE WERE ON A- ASSUME. ARE THE
WORLD WE INHABIT THESE DAYS. A
FEW WEEKS AGO WITH A LARGE
GROUP OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. AND ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT THEY ALSO MADE IN
TERMS OF WORK FORCE IS THAT.
SOME OF THEM ARE SPENDING UP TO
A THIRD OF THE TIME ON
PAPERWORK- FOR THE HEALTH
PLANS- AND SO. TRYING TO. MAYBE
INVEST IN A MORE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT. FOR MENTAL HEALTH
WORKERS SO THAT THEY CAN
MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THEY'RE SPENDING. WITH PATIENCE
AND MINIMIZE. YOUR TIME WOULD
ALSO BE HELPFUL IS THERE A LOT
OF THINGS WE CAN DO AN
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE HEALTH
PLANS. AND PROVIDERS CAN MAKE.
TO REALLY- IT. INCREASES
LIFESAVING- RESOURCE. AND
FINALLY IN TERMS OF THE- TEN
DAYS AND THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
FOR THE QUESTION. ON NOTHING
REQUIRES. A PROVIDER. TO DO TO
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT EVERY TEN
DAYS OF THE PROVIDER THINKS IT
SHOULD BE LONGER. AND THE BILL
PROVIDES THAT IF THE- IF THE
PATIENT IS. SAYS NO I DON'T
WANT TO BE TREATED. WORK OR
KEEPS CANCELING- THAT IS NOT ON
THE HEALTH PLAN- AND IF THE
PLAN SAYING THAT THE LANGUAGE
ISN'T CLEAR ENOUGH ON THAT AND
OF COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S AS CLEAR
AS A COMMITTEE. ON WITHOUT
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU IS THERE MOTION ON THIS
BILL AS I SEE CENTER EGGS. ALL
RIGHT SO THIS BEEN MOVED BY SO
EGGMAN THE BOW FOR A TWO TWO IS
DUE. AS A TO. SEPARATELY CALL
THE ROLL PAN HI CAN HI
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HER TADO I HER TADO BY LEYVA
LEYVA HIGHLY MON. SENATOR LIMON
SCTV TWO ONE HI LIMON AYE ROTH
OR ROTH AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER HI NINETY. THE
BILL CURRENTLY HAS IS NINE ZERO
WILL HOLD THE BILL IN CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO A CONSENT CALENDAR THREE
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FIVE
FORTY ONE BY BATES ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR BY
CORTES THE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TO ANYONE BY DODD IS OUR MOTION
MOVED TO CONTAIN GALLAGHER ALL
RIGHTS BEEN MOVED CENTER EGGMAN
SECRETARIES CALDERON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. PAN HI CAN HI
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I GROW HI
GROUP I HER TADO. HER TOTAL AYE
LEYVA LEYVA AYE LIMóN. SENATOR
LIMON CONSENT CALENDAR I LIMON
I ROTH. I RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER AYE
RIGHT SANTANDER'S TEN ZERO-
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER LET'S NOW- GO
BACK AND OPEN THE ROLE- WHAT'S
GOING AUTHOR ORDER- SO FIRST OF.
WE HAVE- ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
SEVEN FORTY NINE BY GLACIER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROW. I DROVE
BY. APARTADO FIVE FOR TOTAL AYE
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE WIENER RIGHT
WIENER HI EVERYONE. THAT BILL
IS ABOUT ELEVEN ZERO. NEXUS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TWO NIGHT
THREE BY LOW MOAN A SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROW AYE GROVE AYE HER
TADO FOR TITLE HI. THE BILL IS
ABOUT A ZERO- LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX- SB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT BY LOW MULLIN-
SECRET PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWTH NO
GROWTH NO HER TADO HI HURTADO
HI. OKAY THE BILL IS NINE NINE
ELEVEN NINE TWO OKAY THE BILL'S
NINE TO THAT BILL IS OUT- NINE
TWO LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TWO FIFTY
FIVE HAND SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ. GROW NO GROWTH NO.
OKAY THE BELINDA'S. OKAY SO
RIGHT NOW I HAVE NINE ONE. OKAY
THE BILL CURRENTLY IS NINE ONE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER- LET'S NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB THREE
FORTY NINE BY I'M BURKE- SIX
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE RULES
ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ GROW I
GROW HI OKAY THAT BILLS TEN
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBER. FINALLY
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB TWO
TO ONE BY CENTER WIENER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS. MELENDEZ. OKAY THAT
BILL STILL AT NINE ZERO WILL
CALL THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER- SO. SERGEANTS IF YOU
CAN PLEASE- THE- CONTACTS AND
THE WINDOWS OF. YEAH DO NOT
COMING DOWN OKAY ALL RIGHT- SO
SHE. YEAH YEAH YEAH- UHHUH.
UHHUH YES MY.
OKAY LIVE WE'RE
GOING TO RE OPEN THE ROLE- FOR
THE- BILLS ON CALL SO THE NEXT
ALONG CALL IS SO THE NEXT ITEM
ON CALL IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S.
B. TWO FIFTY- BY PAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME
MEMBERS MELENDEZ. OKAY THE VOTE
IS NINE THE BILL IS OUT. NINE
ONE. NEXT ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB THREE FORTY NINE BY
I'M BURKE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ. THAT BILL IS OUT. TEN
ZERO. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB TWO TO ONE BY WIENER
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ GROVE.
THE BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO. NEXT
FINALLY IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
US PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT TEN ZERO
WITH THAT. THIS CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE- STAFF FOR. YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK HERE TODAY AND
KEEPING OUR TELEPHONIC SERVICE
ARE MODERATORS WELL WENT VERY
SMOOTHLY TODAY. I APPRECIATE
IT. ALSO HELPING ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS FOR A REMOTE
MEMBERS AS WELL AS OUR
TESTIMONY WITH THAT- THANKS
VERY MUCH AND- WE ARE HAS
INCLUDED GENDER WE ARE
ADJOURNED.